mes bien chers abonnés pardonnez moi car
j'ai péché car dans le dernier paléo
news j'avais pas bien vérifier mes
sources
échec de rim en plus bonjour à toutes et
à tous oui dans le dernier paléo news
gemalto enfin j'aurais pu mieux faire on
va dire niveau vérifiées de sources
notamment par rapport à cet article si
cet article si donc qui a annoncé la
découverte d'empreintes humaine en
amérique du nord plus vieille que
normalement l'origine l'origine de
l'homme en amérique du nord enfin
l'arrivée de loeb en amérique du nord
oui mais si j'avais mieux regarder les
images j'aurais vu qu'il ya certaines de
ces empreintes qui ont six doigts de
pied oui celle-là 1 2 3 4 5 6 voilà il
me semble qu'un à une auto si je crois
que c'est celle-là 1 2 3 4 5 6
c'est c'est bizarre
c'est bizarre j'aurais dû vérifier ça
avant alors là l'article la découverte
n'a pas encore été validé voire même
remise en question par qui que ce soit
même pas sur les réseaux sociaux j'ai
regardé il ya même pas sur les réseaux
sociaux ça a été remis en question mais
je trouve ça bizarre alors que je
revenais pour mon excuse je revenais du
terrain voilà et je n'avais je n'ai pas
vraiment eu le temps en fait j'ai fait
le paléo news en revenant et du coup
j'ai pas vraiment eu le temps de faire
un peu de recherche sur l'article en
question d'autant que c'est de
l'archéologie c'est quand même assez
loin de mon domaine de compétence mais
je trouve ça bizarre ses six petits
orteils sens qu'à un moment dans la
vidéo je le dis que je dis un truc du
genre c elles sont un peu on a
l'impression qu'elles sont trop belles
pour être vraies c'est emprunter
effectivement
je serais pas surpris que dans un futur
proche
quelqu'un nous dise qu'elle était
effectivement un petit peu trop belle
pour être vraie ceci étant dit elles ne
sont pas tous trop belle pour être vraie
celle là notamment la celle du bas ça
c'est une empreinte de pas qui ressemble
quand même à quelque chose d'un peu plus
classique donc bon on va dire que c'est
ok on va dire que pour l'instant ça n'a
pas été questionné par des vrais experts
pour l'instant les experts semblent
d'accord pour dire que ça passe alors ma
foi bas ça passe voilà et puis on a ce
fameuse ce fameux cratère d'impact qui
aurait provoqué la disparition d'une
ville entière pendant l'antiquité et qui
a été donc mise en parallèle avec la
disparition de sodome et gomorrhe dans
la bible et du coup il ya pas mal de
sceptiques sur les réseaux sociaux qui
se sont penchés sur la question bah oui
évidemment parce que une découverte
scientifique qui a qui validerait entre
guillemets un récit biblique ça fait
chier beaucoup de ça fait chier beaucoup
les sceptiques notamment le ceux qui
défendent l'athéisme bas parce que ça
donne de la crédibilité au récit
biblique alors du coup les sceptiques
ils se sont rués dessus
clamant que la l'étude étaient fausses
personnellement un bon pour avoir lu re
l'article en diagonale j'ai rien trouvé
de d'extravagant dedans je veux dire
comme j'ai dit ah il montre des quartz
choqué il montre des choses
qui sont pas complètement insensé je
veux dire en même temps moi je suis
encore une fois je suis parent que là où
je suis géologue y en a qui ont quand
même souligner qu'il ya des certaines
photos qui ont l'air d'être truquée je
sais pas si je les montre dedans si je
le cij en montre il y en a une en
particulier qui avait l'air d'être
truquée je crois que c'est une de
celles-là en fait tout dans un des coins
il ya des des segments d'image répéter
donc il ya des segments d'image copier
coller ça c'est vrai que c'est c'est une
pratique qui se retrouve quand même
plutôt chez les charlots que chez les
scientifiques mais bon il ya des siens
des fois des fois on fait juste ça il ya
des gens qui font ça juste pour effacer
une barre d'échelle qui était un peu
crasseuse je sais pas honnêtement je
n'en sais rien donc pour l'instant il ya
encore une fois il n'y a pas eu de
réponse officielle des autorités
archéologiques dans le domaine il ya eu
surtout des youtuber aider des gens sur
les réseaux sociaux qui se sont plaints
que que ça tombait un peu trop bien j'ai
pas envie de j'ai pas envie de croire
plus les sceptiques enfin comment dire
j'ai pas envie de plus croire ceux qui
militent contre la religion que ceux qui
militent pour voilà c'est à dire que les
paroles militante globalement ça
m'intéresse pas donc les gens qui sont
sceptiques parce que ça valide la perla
la parole biblique et que du coup faut
surtout pas validé la parole biblique ça
m'intéresse pas plus que les gens qui
cherchent absolument à valider la parole
biblique donc voilà ce qui me permet de
transitionner vers ma pénitence la
prochaine fois je ferai mieux mon fact
checking
ma pénitence aujourd'hui ça va être une
vidéo comment envoyer au monde a envoyée
au moins deux des vidéos on en a envoyé
une autre qui est un documentaire mais
alors le documentaire ayant été au plo
des sur une chaîne que j'ai déjà fait la
fameuse chaîne la fameuse chaîne
d'albator j'ai pas envie de m'en prendre
deux fois la même personne d'une et en
plus ce documentaire on l'a déjà débuté
dans une autre vidéo alors si c'est le
documentaire qui vous parle en long en
large et en travers de la du flat gel
et le flagelle on en a parlé dans notre
vidéo sur l'intelligente design voilà
donc voilà dans cette vidéo là on vous
parle du flagelle des bactéries et on
vous parle des de l'adn dans kg et enfin
c'est une vidéo d'une heure qui vous
expliquent que le flagelle des bactéries
et l'adn c'est trop compliqué ça peut
pas être apparue tout seul la réponse et
si si si tout à fait c'est trop
compliqué en fait c'est ça que les
créationnistes n'arrive pas à comprendre
c'est que le flagelle et l'adn c'est
trop compliqué c'est pas que c'est même
trop compliqué c'est inutilement
compliquée le principe d'un design d'un
dessein intelligent c'est que ça a été
fait intelligemment c'est le principe
c'est dans le nom un le dessein
intelligent ça a été fait intelligemment
6 et stupidement compliqué à un niveau
où ça devrait pas l'être parce qu'il ya
des moyens plus simple d'y arriver
d'arriver au même résultat
c'est pas du dessein intelligent et
c'est au contraire une conséquence
attendue de l'évolution de la sélection
naturelle je rappelle qu'il ya des trucs
qui s'appelle des algorithmes
évolutionnaire ou algorithmes
évolutionniste ses algorithmes on les
utilise pour résoudre des problèmes
d'ingénierie
qu'on n'arrive pas à résoudre avec nos
propres cerveau ou avec des algorithmes
normaux
ces algorithmes évolutionniste tiennent
leur nom du fait qu'il fonctionne à
coups de sélection naturelle
c'est-à-dire qu'il
hills et vos appareils font évoluer des
formes dans tous les sens et là et un
filtre de sélection enlève les formes
les moins optimale essart et évoluent
dans tous les sens et on enlève les
formes les moins optimale et ainsi de
suite on répète l'opération exactement
comme les mutations font évoluer dans
tous les sens et la sélection naturelle
enlève ce qui ne marche pas
ce qui fait que l'évolution n'est pas
comme on l'a expliqué maintes et maintes
fois l'évolution n'est pas un phénomène
dû au hasard voilà donc il y a une part
de hasard la mutation et il ya une part
de sélection le hasard et le fuel la
sélection est le moteur voilà bref donc
aujourd'hui on va s'attaquer à une vidéo
qu'on m'a renvoyé qui s'appelle
évolution contre dieu
qui est en anglais mais sous titrée en
français et qui est en fait une sorte de
micro trottoir je n'ai pas regardé ce
comme d'habitude ça ne m'intéresse pas
mais bon faut bien que je souffre alors
je vais me la faire 38 minutes quand
même ça va être long ça va être dur ça
va faire mal 38 minutes mais il ya un
générique
je suis sauvé par le générique de fin
une minute quand même deux merci de
générique de fin
donc c'est un genre de micro trottoir
c'est à dire que c'est vraiment la
poubelle de l'enquète le micro trottoir
je le rappelle
le micro trottoir c'est comment je te
comment je t'attrape quelqu'un par
surprise je lui pose une question il n'a
pas le temps de réfléchir donc il va te
donner une réponse qui sera plus ou
moins y réfléchit et après je fais du
montage pour enlever les réponses qui me
plaisent pas voilà le micro trottoir
c'est la poubelle de l'information c'est
pour ça qu'il y en a dans les journaux
c'est pour ça que vous en trouvez dans
les journaux télé tout le temps je ne
regarde pas les journaux télé
précisément parce que les prix les
micro-trottoirs ça me gonfle mais du
d'horreur c'est la pire chose que tu
puisse inventer pour pouvoir occuper du
temps d'écran quoi du micro trottoir et
là c'est une vidéo de 38 minutes de
micro trottoir
vous le sentez que ça va vous le sentez
que ça va me plaire
mais j'ose espérer qu'à travers ce micro
trottoir quand même j'ai de l'espoir que
d'accueillir des questions intéressantes
donc on va peut-être y aura des
questions pertinentes peut-être même que
je vais me retrouver coincé ce serait
intéressant justement que je me retrouve
coincé à pas pouvoir répondre je n'en
attends pas autant que ça toutefois pour
être tout à fait honnête je pense que ce
sont des questions très stupide et que
les gens qu'ils auront interviewés qui
seront soit des gens où qu'ils vivent
dans la rue soit des autorités des
autorités scientifiques ou delà de la
militance anti religieuse je pense que
ces gens auront été pris par surprise
voilà
et puis qu'ils n'auront pas eu le temps
de préparer une bonne réponse et même
s'il avait fait une bonne réponse de
toute façon vous imaginez bien que un
documentaire intitulé évolution contre
dieu ne va pas à sélectionner les
réponses qu'ils arrangent pas va
sélectionner les réponses qui l'arrangé
pas les réponses qu'il arrange pas bon
bref 4 millions de vues 4 millions de
vues
4 millions de vu un ratio
deux tiers/un tiers on va dire de pouce
vert quand même ma petite contribution
pouces roule même sans avoir vu la vidéo
c'est cadeau ces cadeaux vous pouvez
m'appeler [ __ ]
encore une vidéo
encore une vidéo de créationnistes
chrétiens oui je n'y peux rien
l'internet est dominé par les
créationnistes chrétiens il ya des gens
qui se plaignent que je fais pas assez
de créationnisme musulmans mais de toute
façon des créationnistes musulmans il
partage sa
je veux dire il ya des villes il ya des
vidéos il ya des kilomètres de contenu
de
de créationnisme chrétiens pourquoi tu
veux qu'ils s'emmerdent à créer des
vidéos originales le dire tu remplaces
dieu parole
c'est exactement les mêmes arguments et
c'est eux mêmes ils repartent à ge ses
vidéos là donc bon y'a pas d'ailleurs je
suis sûr que même tu regardes la dent
les commentaires tu trouve des trucs
gloire à la et des trucs comme ça mais
aucun problème donc oui les
créationnistes musulmans ils vont pas
réinventer la roue ça sert à rien de
réinventer la roue tous les arguments
sont là ils ont qu'à l'ére piocher
copier coller et basta quoi donc
critiquer ça c'est aussi critiqué le
créationnisme musulmans le créationnisme
c'est du créationnisme il n'a pas
d'originalité il ya des petites
originalités dans le créationnisme
musulmans notamment le concordisme mais
à la limite le concordisme mais encore
une fois c'est
à la limite moins problématique que du
créationnisme brut dans le sens où ils
admettent
c'est à une sorte d'intelligence design
on va dire voilà donc c'est moins pire
que du créationnisme terreau jeune quoi
bon c'est moins pire
[Rires]
bref c'est une vidéo qui est très très
longue donc je pense qu'on va s'en va
s'y coller tout de suite et puis de
toute façon j'ai déjà fait des trucs sur
le créationnisme musulmans puisque j'ai
déjà critiquée
j'ai fait pas mal de vidéos critique
enfin j'ai fait une grosse vidéo
critiques sur harun yahya qui a elle
même inspiré une série de vidéos
critique qui a été publiée par jugantor
app store donc
petite citation de richard dawkins
évidemment s'attend non le 2 comme il
est connu dans le milieu
donc voilà donc et puis j'ai fait ça et
puis je j'ai fait moi j'ai fait une
vidéo moi même je des bonnes kg et une
vidéo où je tenais des propos à la
limite du concordisme ça compte quand
même comme du déblocage
donc déjà de base bon en même temps là
c'est le titre de la vidéo un évolution
contre dieu mais directement ça va être
à propos de l'athéisme donc déjà hors
sujet c'est je veux dire j'ai même pas
besoin de regarder une vidéo comme ça
plus de 45 secondes voyez on est à 45
secondes j'ai pas besoin de la regarder
à plus de 45 secondes pour vous dire
déjà hors sujet la vidéo va le but avoué
de cette vidéo elle donc de critiquer
l'athéisme et pour ça va passer par la
case évolution
hors sujet c'est tout je veux dire hors
sujet et mauvaise foi je la sens venir
parce que quand tu essayes de quand tu
veux prendre d'évolution pour la
contorsionner pour la faire rentrer dans
la case vous voyez les athéistes 11h les
athées ont tort
ça ça semble ça sent la mauvaise foi
quoi ça sent la grosse grosse grosse
mauvaise mauvaise foi
donc ça ouvre la porte disons à la
malhonnêteté intellectuelle
ça veut pas dire qu'ils vont l'utiliser
la malhonnêteté intellectuelle mais ça
ouvre la porte clairement quand tu
essayes de prouver un truc par enfin
quand tu essayes de prouver à utiliser
l'évolution pour prouver quelque chose
d'autre de toute façon généralement ce
que tu vas te planter
globalement
le débat classique atelier maastricht
donc voilà j'imagine que on a fait le
micro trottoir et on a sélectionné
évidemment comme des abris à réconforte
c'est vrai qu'on me forte qui a fait la
vidéo youpi
la gran apologètes un grand apologètes
d'un grand nom du créationnisme rail
combi shorts et bas super évidemment le
sous titre se
se vante évidemment veut nous faire
savoir du coup que c'est vrai comme
forte
qui a fait la vidéo
appel à l'autorité donc
voilà et là il avait il a bien gardé sa
louis do you believe in évolutions y ait
said ou est ce que tu crois en
l'évolution oui as tu crois en
l'évolution voilà il a bien gardé vous
voyez la personne qui a répondu oui je
crois en l'évolution il n'a pas gardé la
personne qui a dit un homme en un an moi
je pense que l'évolution est vrai basée
sur les preuves il n'a pas gardé
l'interview de ces gens là il a gardé
celle de celui qui dit je crois en les
matchs
dont l'évolution peut transformer les
dinosaures en oiseaux les singes en
humains et les dauphins ont subi en
malaise alors l'évolution peut faire ça
oui mais après faut pas oublier que
c'est un petit bout de phrase sortie de
son contexte qui explique des choses en
une phrase donc évidemment ça ça peut
avoir l'air ridicule si tu présentes de
cette façon là évidemment
oui ça c'est important à rappeler c'est
que l'évolution c'est effectivement ses
lacets expliquer l'origine de la
biodiversité d'une façon complètement
naturel c'est à dire sans faire
intervenir de de forces extérieures
surnaturel donc les extraterrestres ou
dieu par exemple typiquement
beaucoup de gens
personnifie la sélection naturelle en
dix ans la sélection naturelle a fait
pousser des ailes aux oiseaux par
exemple je dis ça
c'est un peu justement revenir en
arrière sur le concept d'évolution de ce
point de vue là c'est à dire que si vous
personnifiez la sélection naturelle vous
en faites entre guillemets un dieu faut
bien être d'accord que la sélection
naturelle c'est juste un phénomène
statistiques au final c'est la sélection
des des sur une courbe de variation d'un
trait d'un trait anatomiques en
particulier ou génétiques voilà la
sélection naturelle c'est juste ce qui
va enlever les côtés voilà les extrêmes
qui ne fonctionne pas donc soit ça
enlève les deux extrêmes et vous avez
stabilisation du caractère soit vous
avez qu un extrême qui enlevait l'autre
extrême étant pas spécialement grave et
dans ce cas là vous avez des placements
de cette courbe ce qui résout ce qui
résulte en un phénomène statistiques
encore une fois de dévolution en fait
d'un caractère évolution qui sera
d'abord du domaine de la micro évolution
jusqu'à ce qu'elles soient irréversibles
et deviennent donc macro évolutive
irréversible encore une fois on peut
parler de l'irréversibilité d'évolution
quand un gène ne peut plus revenir en
arrière c'est à dire que vous pouvez
revenir en arrière sur un caractères
morphologiques
voilà si vous perdez un doigt le doigt
peut revenir plusieurs millions d'années
plus tard c'est le matériel génétique
n'a pas été trop altérés mais quoi qu'il
arrive les mutations qui ont eu lieu
dans un sens pour faire disparaître le
doigt ne pourront pas avoir lieu dans
l'autre sens exactement donc l'évolution
dans ce sens est
irréversible mais ces statistiques faut
bien pouvoir le côté où c'est un
phénomène qui essentiellement
statistiques la sélection naturelle
c'est faut pas voir ça comme un
phénomène une pression qui existe
réellement c'est à dire comme voilà
comme un truc qu'ils appuieraient c'est
pas un truc qu'ils appuieraient quand on
parle de pression de sélection c'est pas
un truc qui appuient c'est un phénomène
global qui résultent y a pour résultat
de
d'enclencher une dérive des traits
c'est voilà faut c'est juste un
avertissement pour dire qu'il faudrait
pas non plus et je pense que c'est j'ai
l'impression si je dis ça en fait si je
passe du temps à expliquer ça c'est
parce que je pense qu'il va aller de ce
côté là j'ai comme l'impression qu'il ya
un moment il va nous dire mais dit non
votre sélection naturelle n'est pas un
peu divine je me demande s'il va pas
aller dans cette direction là mais on va
voir
baigne en plein dedans vous croyez que
c'est une vous pensez que c'est une
croyance en évolution et
ding l'oracle
ce sont des faits évidemment que ce sont
des faits
exactement
j'ai l'impression que du coup le but du
micro trottoir ça va être de faire
admettre aux gens que c'est un c'est une
croyance
jusque évidemment quand tu attrapes les
gens sur dans la rue comme ça bah
évidemment que tu vas
quand tu attrapes les gens comme ça ils
n'ont pas le temps vraiment de réfléchir
ce qu'ils vont juger vous avez
d'ailleurs des trucs qui m'ont fait
beaucoup marré c'est un micro-trottoir
de gens qui aient un emploi l'entretien
épistémique j'ai plus qui c'est qui
avait fait ça et il ya beaucoup de
sceptiques qui ont une admiration pour
ce truc l'entretien épistémique qui est
ni plus ni moins que de la manipulation
mentale 1 donc déjà éthiquement
éthiquement parlant c'est moyen moyen
d'entretiens épistémique mais bref et
donc et qui est qu'ils partageaient à un
moment je crois que c'était il ya deux
trois ans la vidéo de ce mec qui prenait
un croyant et qui genre le retourner
comme une chaussette pendant un micro
trottoir
a votre avis il en a foiré combien avant
de mettre ce micro trottoir en ligne
donc voilà le micro trottoir c'est pas
je critique pas les micro-trottoirs que
quand ça m'arrange pas les sceptiques
qui utilisent mal les micro trottoirs
gelés
et je les aime pas non plus que le mec
qui prétend retourner quelqu'un comme
une chaussette pendant un entretien
épistémique pendant un micro-trottoir
oui c'est bon t'as attraper un mec par
surprise il a fini par admettre ce que
tu voulais entendre juste pour tu lui
foute la paix
mais bref
c'est déjà mal barré quand tu parles de
fossiles quand on vous parle
quand on vous dit l'évolution nana est
ce que ça marche tout ça faut pas
commencer par les fossiles les fossiles
c'est probablement une des pires preuve
en fait parce qu'il ya trop de il ya
beaucoup trop de trous dans le registre
fossile qui sont autant d'espacés où les
créationnistes peuvent aller s'infiltrer
en fait vous commencez par la génétique
vous balancer la génétique n'y a aucune
raison que les espèces modernes est le
même adn si elles n'ont pas si elles ne
l'ont pas hérité d'un ancêtre en commun
point barre c'est l'adn la réponse
commencer par l'adn
voyez la phrase hors contexte magnifique
la méthode scientifique c'est la
collecte de données par l'observation et
l'expérimentation
il ya les trois petits points à la fin
ce qui veut dire que la phrase est pas
finir
mais pourtant on va rester là-dessus la
collecte de data et l'expérimentation
alors la collecte de données
l'expérimentation ça fait de vous un
gamin de 3 ans c'est ce qu'un gamin de 3
en fait ils collectent des données voilà
il échoue et nice ni dit me met tout
dans sa bouche ils collectent des
données il expérimente ça fait pas lui
un scientifique c'est c'est le doute
systématique la remise en question et là
on va dire que ce qui va faire la
différence entre un scientifique et un
nom scientifique une méthode
scientifique et de méthodes non
scientifique c'est la confiance finale
dans un consensus d'experts c'est ça la
grosse différence c'est que vous pouvez
prendre un scientifique comme par
exemple au hasard didier raoult et ce
scientifique va vous dire des trucs
et ses trucs seront éminemment faux
mais c'est pas la science qui lui donne
raison c'est le consensus scientifique
qui lui donnent raison or didier raoult
tout ce qui dit il est tout seul à le
dire
il ya peut-être à la rigueur montagne et
qu'ils l'accompagnent mes montagnes et
avec tout le prix nobel qui là bas il
dit aussi des conneries parce qu'il a
aucun consensus scientifique derrière ce
qui donne foi à la parole d'un
scientifique c'est le consensus qui a
derrière c'est le fait que tout le monde
soit d'accord ou en tout cas 90% de la
communauté scientifique soit d'accord
c'est ça la différence entre la science
et la patience
celle qui s'émousse en ce moment alors
que vous m'écoutez que vous m'écoutez on
en est à 2 minutes de vidéo trois
minutes de vidéo vous en avais déjà
marre de m'entendre je suis sûr bref la
science c'est pas la collecte des
données l'expérimentation un gamin de 3
ans et faire ça la science c'est la
confiance qu'on accorde dans un
consensus d'experts
cités sciencedaily
un magazine scientifique enfin je veux
dire sciences et avenir
encore une fois tu vois il a sélectionné
le mec qui te parle 665 millions
les fossiles à chaque fois vous
commettez l'erreur est c'est un
paléontologue qui vous lie arrêter de
prendre les fossiles comme bon exemple
d'évolution sera une petite
vg10 le registre fossile il est plein de
petits trous il s'infiltre la génétique
la preuve évidente que les espèces
évoluent et la génétique on a tous les
mêmes gènes pourquoi est-ce que j'ai les
mêmes gènes qu'une grenouille ils sont
juste activé différemment vous prenez
l'anatomie des espèces modernes voilà
pourquoi le cerveau d'un chimpanzé est
juste le est le même que celui d'un être
humain juste avec un néo cortex plus
petits pourquoi pourquoi il y a aucun os
chez le chimpanzé qu'on ne retrouve pas
chez l'homme parce que vous pouvez
vérifier il n'existe aucun os chez le
chimpanzé qu'on ne retrouve pas chez
l'homme chez une souris il y en aura d
eau que notamment la queue par exemple
que vous retrouverez chez une souris que
vous ne trouverez pas chez l'homme donc
nous sommes moins apparentes et chez le
chimpanzé on a tous les os ils sont
juste différent en proportion c'est tout
enfin proportion voilà en forme donc
voilà prenez l'anatomie prenez la
distribution des espèces pourquoi les
marsupiaux serait-il en australie
s'il n'y a pas une histoire derrière ça
je veux dire si toutes les espèces sont
apparus ping comme ça d'un coup pourquoi
est ce que les marsupiaux serait comme
ça qu'on finit en australie alors ouais
y en a qu il y en a 2 3 en amérique du
sud la belle affaire j'ai envie de dire
mais voilà façon au pareil on pourrait
parler du confinement sud-américain
aussi dans ce cas donc alan s'il n'y a
pas une histoire derrière pourquoi
pas rebelle des buts
aurait-il des dior est il des marsupiaux
que en australie et en amérique du sud
bon bah bref tout ça quoi c'est prenez
des exemples de la nature moderne voilà
pourquoi est-ce que j'ai des pouces
opposables comme un singe pourquoi
est-ce que j'ai des ongles et pas des
griffes 1 les griffes qu'on retrouve
chez les chats chez les chevaux pourquoi
moi j'ai des ongles et passa par contre
les singes aussi ils ont des angles
pourquoi est-ce que pourquoi est ce que
mes deux au fronton et mas un fils
mandibulaire sont fusionnés exactement
comme les autres singes pourquoi est-ce
que je n'ai que deux paires d'incisives
comme les autres singes mais comme aucun
autre mammifère
voilà là là on commence à poser des
questions intéressantes mais la
paléontologie faut faut pas l'amener la
paléontologie c'est un argumentaire qui
devient intéressant mais a posteriori
une fois que vous avez établi qu'au
hockey dans la nature actuelle il ya
beaucoup de choses qui semblent nous
indiquer que l'évolution fonctionne
est-ce que la paléontologie dit le
contraire la réponse est non et là ça
devient un argument fort parce qu'il y
aurait toutes les chances de trouver un
homo sapiens à trois milliards d'années
je veux dire y'a pas de raison sylla si
l'évolution ne marche pas il n'y a pas
de raison qu'on trouve pas un homo
sapiens dans des roches viennent de 3
milliards d'années on n'en trouve pas il
n'y a pas de raison qu'on ne trouve pas
de
d'êtres humains en présence de
trilobites même si vous croyez pas aux
aux dates admettons vous croyez pas que
la terre puisse avoir trois milliards
d'années vous croyez pas aux dates mais
on devrait quand même trouvé des
trilobites avec des homo sapiens et on
les trouve pas ces trilobites avec ces
homo sapiens est en tout cas à chaque
fois qu'on en trouve
cdc défaut ou des mauvaises
interprétations absolument évidente
voilà il ya les empreintes de pas de
dinosaures qu'on retrouve sur 10 ans
avec des empreintes de pieds humains
c'est on voit que les empreintes de
pieds humains ont été
soit là ça a été fabriquée de toutes
pièces enfin le dire il n'y a pas de on
devrait trouver de l'être humain partout
dans le registre fossile s'il y avait
s'il s'y l'être humain avait été créé en
même temps que tout le reste ce n'est
pas le cas ce n'est pas le cas
donc bon et puis pas si si vous aimez
alors après il ya évidemment les gens
qui disent maintenant les trous mais il
a été pris et créer le sixième jour
été créée après le reste donc le reste
du registre fossile c'est ce qu'il ya
avant et bien dans ce cas joker la
disparition des espèces personne ne
niera que les espèces peuvent
disparaître on le voit on le voit on
voit ça arrive et je veux dire personne
ne niera que le dodo a disparu par
exemple donc la disparition des espèces
est un phénomène qui est reconnu par
tout le monde y compris les
créationnistes pourquoi quand on compte
les fossiles on constate une
augmentation de la diversité
augmentation de la diversité qui est un
chacune conséquences absolument attendu
de l'évolution qui est l'exact opposé de
la conséquence attendue d'une création
la création c'est soit ça stagne
mais comme il ya des extinctions ça doit
pas stagner normalement ça doit
descendre voilà donc pourquoi quand on
compte les espèces dans le registre
fossile
ça augmente et ben voilà mais ces voix
là c'est le registre fossile c'est un
argument qui vient après n'allez pas ne
vous jetez pas sur le registre fossile
dès qu'on vous demande et c'est pour ça
que je disais le micro trottoir c'est
trompeur parce qu'évidemment les gens la
première chose qu on leur dit évolution
d'un fossile
les fossiles ils sont sujets à
interprétation et comme j'ai dit dès les
trous dans le registre fossile sont des
trous
c'est facile de s'infiltrer dedans
alors oui on peut retracer l'évolution à
travers le registre fossile
mais justement là le truc c'est encore
une fois vu que c'est un micro-trottoir
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire ils vont
parler d'archaeopteryx ils vont parler
d'eux ils vont parler des
australopithèques etc qui sont encore
une fois
ils vont parler de fossiles qui sont
très connus des formes de transition qui
sont très connus ils vont pas parler du
registre fossile par exemple des
rongeurs et d aider des organismes des
micro organismes en général des
foraminifères par exemple qu'on peut
tracer je veux dire à la dizaine de
milliers d'années près voire même moins
sort ou des ammonites voilà des
registres fossiles qui sont extrêmement
bien documenté mais qui appartiennent à
des espèces dont on se fout totalement
voilà mais néanmoins on peut voir
l'évolution chez ces bêtes là on peut la
voir directement chez les rongeurs
notamment donc ça c'est voilà c'est le
problème des micro-trottoirs quoi
et donc comme elle le disait est ce que
les est-ce que l'évolution était stable
à travers le temps et elle dit non mais
la réponse est oui l'évolution est tout
à fait t stable à travers le temps bon
déjà parce qu'on peut voir l'évolution
chez des organismes qui évolue vite
comme les bactéries la fameuse
expérience de lenski qui suit
l'évolution de ces bactéries alors à
chaque fois on nous dit ouais mais
l'adaptation
à manger le glucose qui était dans l'est
enfin le pas le glucose mais l'espèce de
sucre qui était dans la boîte de pétri
c'est une adaptation qui existait déjà
oui mais enfin c'est pas la seule chose
qu'on a regardé chez sayabec veut dire
on n'a pas passé 40 ans a regardé une
adaptation chez ces bactéries évidemment
qu'on a regardé tout leur génome
conséquence leur génome à tour de bras
et on voit toutes les modifications du
génome qui ont lieu donc on les voit
évoluer la cemac terre il n'y a pas à
tortiller du cul donc d'une si on arrive
à tester l'évolution en direct en
regardant les organismes qui évolue vite
comme les bactéries et les mouches du
vinaigre
et on arrive à voir arriver et on arrive
à tester l'évolution grâce au registre
fossile avec des hypothèses simple
notamment des hypothèses rétrospective à
savoir que par exemple si les espèces
marines moderne les mammifères marins
modernes descendent d'ancêtres
mammifères terrestres alors il existe
dans le registre fossile des
représentants de ces espèces marines qui
sont à quatre pattes
par exemple les lamantins et pour les
lamantins bas on a le fameux peso sirène
qui est à lamentin à quatre pattes voilà
et dont on a dont on a un squelette
raisonnablement complet comme vous
pouvez le voir très très raisonnablement
complet quand même à ce niveau là
donc voilà et puis aussi rennes c'est
impressionnant parce que c'est vraiment
un corps de lamentin avec quatre pattes
voilà la seule chose qui est reconstitué
chez peso sirène c'est le bout de ses
pieds mais enfin les pattes l on les a
c'est juste le bout des pieds et des
mains qui manquent donc voilà c'est ça
c'est vous poser l'hypothèse vous posez
une hypothèse testable qui est si les
mammifères marins ont évolué à partir
d'ancêtres terrestre alors il existe
dans le registre fossile quelque part un
mammifère marin appartenant au même
groupe qui à quatre pattes alors
qu'aujourd'hui non plus ils n'ont plus
quatre pattes les mails et siréniens
d'aujourd'hui n'ont plus que des petites
palettes natatoire à l'avant mais non
plus de pattes arrière donc voilà c'est
une hypothèse très stable qui peut être
testé
habile citation de richard dawkins qui
qui a écrit ça probablement dans leur
loge et aveugle je vais pomme je vais
même pas m'embêter à aller chercher
parce que je sais que c'est encore une
citation hors sujet je le connais très
bien les écrits de richard dawkins c'est
probablement quelque chose qu'il a
écrits soient dans leur loge et aveugle
le soin d'en
de greatest show on earth et
c'est quelque chose qu'il a probablement
placé dans l'introduction voyez
justement pour dire le contraire dans
les chapitres suivants
donc voilà
ça je suis sûr ou presque allez paris
c'est soit stephen jay gould swan hills
eldredge précisément pour défendre la
théorie des équilibres ponctué qui était
qui est une théorie évolutionniste vas-y
allez allez vas-y vas-y je pensais et au
je suis en train de souffrir alors
j'essaye de rendre ça un peu amusant
hockey
au maire de charles darwin
merde
là non là où c'est encore pire que de
citer l dredge et gould ce qu'est la dre
jay gould ils ont souvent dit ils ont
souvent parlé de stase évolutive et les
créationnistes il adore ça parce que
quand elle dredge et gould parle de
stase évolutif c'est pour ensuite dire
que l'évolution a lieu rapidement par
équilibre ponctué sauf que les
créationnistes il précise juste la
partie qui parle de stase pour en faire
une défense du fait que les espèces
n'évolue pas et en disant hé vous voyez
même le paléontologue stephen jay gould
il l'a dit non là c'est pire les mecs
ils ont pris une phrase de charles
darwin vous savez en qu'à l'époque il a
écrit cela charleville on voit pas de
fossiles on voit pas de forme
transitionnelle dans le registre fossile
signée charles darwin c'était dans les
années 1850
peut-être 1870 enfin je veux dire ça
c'est des écrits qui ont cent cinquante
ans
t'as pas honte de citer des écrits qui
ont cent cinquante ans c
c'est honteux c'est en te
sert de te
faut vraiment être un faut vraiment être
le dernier des malhonnêtes comme je le
disais je les dis au début ça allait
être le festival de lama noté
intellectuelle ceci dit je je je plaide
coupable aussi je regarde ça avec une
très très grande malhonnêteté
intellectuelle
mais la route nettement enfin moi je
n'ai pas écrit et je n'ai pas publié
quoi comme salanon melfort j'allais dire
je n'ai pas publié sur youtube mais si
vous êtes en train de me regarder
non mais bref c'est un truc de fou quoi
c'est un truc de fou de prendre des
phrases de charles darwin en disant il
n'y a pas de registre fossile bah ouais
en
1853 le registre fossile excusez-moi la
paléontologie n'existait même pas ou
presque pas en tant que oui on a du mal
à avoir un registre fossile descend en
1850 même en 1870 même en 1890 veut dire
vous imaginez bien qu'à l'époque de
charles darwin y avait même pas encore
eu la guerre des os entre coppet march
donc il y avait même pas encore eu le
grand rush vers les dinosaures nord
américain vous n'aviez même pas eu
osbourne donc il ya même pas eu t-rex
voilà par exemple t-rex n'existait même
pas encore enfin n'avait pas encore été
nommés t-rex qu'est-ce qui est l'hôte
enfin je veux dire on connaissait rien à
l'époque du registre fossile donc
évidemment que charles darwin a écrit ça
c'est à l'époque de charles darwin n'y
avait même pas il n'y avait même pas
homo erectus ou peut-être que si mais à
l'époque on l'appelait l'homme de java
on l'appeler pithécanthrope il
s'appelait pas homo erectus à l'époque
il s'appelait pithécanthrope ou une
connerie comme ça je venais
à l'époque de charles darwin je crois on
devrait connaître alors charles darwin
pas dans l'édition à au moins pas dans
l'édition originale de l'origine des
espèces mais au moins dans une des
rééditions suivante il devait au moins y
avoir
donc homo erectus le pithécanthrope et
l'homme de néandertal et peut-être au
moyen de leurs gaines si ce n'est pas
sûr du tout je crois qu'il a même pas je
crois que c'était encore pas assez pour
avoir l'homme de piles da sachant claude
depyl d'un après c'était un faux
et que du coup ce n'est pas resté c'est
pas rester dans les annales de la
paléontologie ça a été viré en 1950 mais
voilà donc en gros à l'époque de charles
darwin on connaissait kochi du registre
fossile des êtres humains voient
typiquement donc
oui c'est normal que charles darwin deez
qui a pas de registre fossile il n'y en
avait pas il y en avait effectivement
pas il n'y avait pas de paléontologues
de toute façon
alors oui là il ya le fameux un
changement de kind en anglais est alors
kind c'est donc il ça fait expressément
référence à la bible donc la bible qui
emploie aussi le mot kind pour définir
des pour définir les espèces mais avec
ceux avec cette petite comment dire
avec cette petite subtilité que bah
c'est la bible n'a pas été écrit par des
biologistes donc c'est la définition
d'espèces comme quand on dit que les
dinosaures étaient l'espèce dominante
voilà donc dans la bouche d'un
créationnistes le mot kind il est il est
extrêmement compliqué à définir parce
que il utilise le mot kind comme le
grand public utilisent le mot espèces en
france par exemple
dans le sens où voilà les dinosaures
sont l'espèce dominante web les
dinosaures c'est pas une espèce c'est un
super ordre enfin bref sa robe ça
rassemble des milliers d'espèces
littéralement à les dinosaures donc
donc cesser complètement ses extrêmement
défi difficile à définir ce que c'est un
créationniste entend par kind et là ça a
été traduit par genre et les changements
de genre bah si on en a documenté on en
a totalement documenté mais dans le
registre fossile le registre fossile des
rongeurs
si on va chercher le registre fossile
donc des rongeurs
je crois que c'est harvey cola rongeurs
évolution harvey cola le ça doit être ça
on va aller voir
alors j'ai mis rognard ça risque pas de
marché du coup
rongeurs évolution harvey cola voilà
donc premières molaires inférieur
donc l'évolution du genre harvey cola
dans le registre fossile qu'on a très
très bien documenté alors à henvic aulas
je sais plus je crois que c'est à temps
or nicolas on va aller voir ce que c'est
déjà comme espèces de rongeurs ça
comprend des rongeurs les campagnols
voilà met donc les campagnols on les
voit évoluer au fil du temps dans le
registre fossile du quaternaire
harvey col alors peut-être que je
précise l'auteur jean chaline j'essaie
de trouver les images directement pour
pouvoir vous montrer voilà
magnifique magnifique petit diagramme
regardez-moi ça
donc si on prend le terme genre dans sa
définition la scientifique la plus pure
skis et ski et une triche ce qui est de
la triche comparé à la définition de
genre qu'emploient les créationnistes
puisque genre ça veut dire tout de
l'espèce au super ordre
voilà évidemment vous avez vous avez des
petits problèmes mais voilà les rongeurs
on les voit évoluer donc on voit des
changements de l'espèce et de genre dans
le registre fossile qu'on arrive à
suivre grâce à l'anatomie dentaire dont
ce que vous voyez là c'est l'anatomie
dentaire et là vous voyez une ligne et
la lignée plio pas thomis mine de plio
pas thomis donc clio pas thomis dont
l'espèce se transforme au fil du temps
pour revenir pour devenir le genre on
datera et vous avez normalement darby
cola qui doit être dans le tas donc qui
est le campagnol moderne
ou alors peut-être boj ce pommeau toute
façon ça n'empêche que ce tout ça ce
sont des harvey collinaires donc c'est
la famille du campagnol on reconnaît
bien les dents avec des motifs en v donc
voilà elle a regardé magnifique 1 le
temps en millions d'années
ici la morphologie dentaire représentés
de façon quantifier notamment la hauteur
de la couronne dentaire qui est
représentée donc adaptation un milieu de
plus en plus arides une végétation de
plus en plus riches en
de plus en plus riches en graminées
qu'on voit
arriver au cours du temps avec aussi une
modification du dessin dentaire
modification du dessin dentaire qui
comprend
notamment apparitions et disparitions
ici de ce qu'on appelle le puise les
mi-moyens donc se puise les mi-moyens
qui est ce petit trou que vous voyez là
donc ça c'est un caractère très très
typique qu'on rencontre que chez
certains à andy collines et mimo miss
notamment voilà et donc là on voit une
transformation du genre mimo miss à
travers plusieurs espèces jusqu'aux
genre harvey cola un changement de genre
documenté par le registre fossile comme
demandé
voilà et après si vous voulez des
changements d'espèces
des changements d'espèce on en a parlé
les changements d'espèce on en a parlé
dans entracte science on a une vidéo qui
s'appelle
classifiés je crois que ces
classifications
et rock'n'roll
donc la voie la classification poule est
en quel rôle le web notre vieux
générique
classification poule et rock'n'roll où
on vous donne des exemples des espèces
qu'on voit évoluer un don qu'il ya
notamment les espère que les fameuses
espèces
encerclent donc donc on peut voir
évoluer non pas au fil du temps mais au
fil de la géographie donc chaque espèce
de ces cercles en fait peut se croiser
avec l'espèce suivante mais pas avec
l'espèce
qui est plus loin en fait donc les
espèces sont peuvent se croiser de
proche en proche mais pas avec les
espèces les plus éloignés
géographiquement donc c'est pareil on a
ça aussi chez les salamandres du genre
ans à tina elles peuvent se croiser les
unes les autres de proche en proche mais
celle là par exemple ne peut pas se
croiser avec celle là parce que c'est le
bout du cercle on a évidemment dans le
genre les espèces on à homo sapiens et
homo neandertalensis 1 donc l'homme de
néandertal et l'homo sapiens qui sont
très différents morphologiquement mais
dont on a des preuves d'hybridation donc
des preuves qu'ils étaient en cours de
spéciation en réalité qui n'était qu'il
était déjà une espèce séparer du point
de vue morphologique mais pas du point
de vue
génétique
on a des preuves de transition de
transition morphologiques chez les
poissons plats donc notamment il ya des
poissons qui ont commencé symétrique et
qui en devenant plats ont vu leur oeil
migrer et donc on a en fils tom qui est
un qui est un poisson
fossiles et on a même un autre poisson
fossiles qui est erroné qu't'es qui
documentent aussi
l'évolution des poissons
asymétrique mais surtout ce que je
voulais vous montrer ce sont ces espèces
qu'on voit évoluer on va dire en temps
réel en laboratoire et dont on parle il
me semble un peu plus loin ici voilà
donc les espèces qu'on voit évoluer en
temps en temps réel aujourd'hui un donc
les moustiques des couloirs du métro
londonien donc les moustiques du métro
londonien ne peuvent plus hybride et
avec les moustiques de la surface c'est
donc deux espèces différentes 2
kind comme la bible les décrire les
définit puisque la bible ils sont
définis comme des entités qui ne peuvent
pas se reproduire entre eux donc tout
kinds deux genres différents
ici on a pas d'art 6 le fameux les arts
de l'idpe eaux des mers karouf de
croatie je sais jamais comment prononcer
sa peau de merkel j'en sais rien bref un
lézard qui s'est retrouvé isolé pendant
trente ans sur une île et qui a
développé une nouvelle morphologie de la
mâchoire une nouvelle morphologie
digestive
s'adaptant à l'herbe ivory donc devenant
une nouvelle espèce on est sur le chemin
de la macro évolution donc est ici vous
avez l'espèce une nouvelle espèce de
lézard nommé aspi dossier disent qu'on a
créé en laboratoire
tout simplement en l'hybride en avait en
hybridant deux autres espèces et cette
espèce là en fait elle a un nombre de
chromosomes qui est trop élevé pour
s'hybrider avec les deux autres donc
c'est techniquement une nouvelle espèce
voilà elle ne peut plus hybride et avec
les autres donc oui on est capable de
créer de l'évolution en laboratoire on
est capable de voir l'évolution en
direct et on est capable de la recréer
en laboratoire et de comme je le dis il
ya l'expérience de lenski qui suit
l'évolution des bactéries il ya tout un
tas d'expériences qui suivent
l'évolution des
dés
des drosophiles donc des mouches du
vinaigre donc il ya énormément un de
preuve de l'évolution vu en direct et
dans le temps court et dans le registre
fossile donc qui était la question de
base j'ai envie de dire avec césar
bicolline et
[Musique]
donc l'appareil on est sur un cas de
micro-trottoirs donc qu'est ce qui s'est
passé ils sont partis sur des gros
animaux des chiens des chats
[Musique]
encore une fois encore une fois il a
pris celui qui a dit le mot believe
encore une fois son micro trottoir il a
sélectionné celui qui a dit believe je
crois que c'était y'a trop 60 millions
d'années non on a des preuves que
c'était il ya 65 millions d'années des
preuves génétiques que sont là
l'horloge moléculaire et d'épreuves
fossiles basé sur la première occurrence
des chiens enfin des canidés decani
formes et des faits les formes dans le
registre fossile voilà c'est ça qu'il
aurait dû dire mais évidemment sur un
micro trottoir tu peux pas tout balancer
comme ça parce que tous ne te vient pas
à l'esprit
est ce assez
c'est de la malhonnêteté encore une fois
c'est de la malhonnêteté intellectuelle
c'est la malhonnêteté et comme j'ai dit
sont tombés dans le piège de parler de
mes livres macro mammifères de gros
mammifères au lieu de parler des
micromammifères comme les rongeurs
[Musique]
pareil encore encore le piège du micro
trottoir donc ouais on se dirige
clairement vers quelqu'un qui veut dire
faire dire aux gens que
que penser que l'évolution est vrai est
une croyance
ce qui est bas ce qui est déjà un
problème en soi puisque le mec il a
juste les manipuler le dire il va juste
manipuler leurs discours pendant le
micro trottoir
mais on sait que la révolution n'est pas
une croyance puisque l'évolution est
basé sur des preuves voilà il n'arrête
pas de le répéter qu'il ya des preuves
donc l'évolution est basé sur des
preuves dont j'ai déjà fait moult et
moult liste jusqu'à présent et là on est
juste en train en fait de jouer sur les
mots parce que c'est pas c'est pas qu'il
faut avoir la foi en les preuves
scientifiques ou ans les scientifiques
c'est on a la confiance envers les
scientifiques on a confiance envers
l'épreuve est d'où est tirée cette
confiance elle est tirée d'une part de
l' expertise des scientifiques eux mêmes
du consensus c'est à dire du fait que
les scientifiques sont tous d'accord
entre malgré le fait qu'ils ont des
intérêts divergents 1 je me rappelle
lé laboratoire de paléontologie de
biologie de génétique et tout ça ils
travaillent sur les enfin ils sont
censés tirer leur argent des mêmes
sources de financement donc ils se
battent entre eux et pourtant il arrive
à des conclusions convergentes donc
malgré le fait que leurs intérêts soient
divergent le fait que leurs conclusions
soient convergentes c'est une preuve
très forte qu'on peut leur faire
confiance
et cette confiance elle se base sur le
fait que les preuves vous pouvez les
voir vous même en allant dans les musées
en allant questionner les les chercheurs
en regardant c'est pas sorcier
bon c'est pas sorcier ça n'existe plus
vraiment mais en regardant les
reportages à la télé enfin je veux dire
que vous pouvez voir ses preuves si vous
faîtes l'effort au moins d'aller voir
d'aller les voir le dira évidemment on
va pas vous allez pas vous réveiller un
matin avec toutes les preuves sur le nez
quoi évidemment mais si vous faites
l'effort d'aller voir les preuves vous
les verrez on pourra vous les montrer
y'a pas de soucis il ya jamais eu de
souci
voilà donc encore une fois démarche
malhonnêtes qui consiste à faire dire
aux gars que il a la foi en l'évolution
alors que c'est pas vrai il a la
confiance il a la confiance dans le
consensus scientifique et dans l'épreuve
c'est un gros changement voilà
exactement de chain of canine le
changement entre le chimpanzé alors là
déjà la traduction est foireuse parce
que c'est pas imposer les hommes c'est
il a dit manque qu'il a dit singer
hommes et
les singes seller cercopithèque aux ide
et les catarhiniens 1
c'est à dire les les babouins et les
singes de l'ancien et les singes du
nouveau monde ça c'est ce qu'on appelle
des sages donc là c'est pas seulement un
changement de ce n'est pas seulement un
changement de genre comme entre le
chimpanzé et l'homme japonais du genre
pan est l'homme du genre homo c'est un
changement de type changement de famille
de primates total
on voyait là le flou le cloud est le
choix de l'emprunt du mot kind il est il
et il n'est pas anodin il absolument pas
anodin c'est de la manipulation encore
une fois hélas hélas en plus ils
demandent sache
chemistry major donc le mec il est même
pas chimiste il est
major je sais pas ce que ça veut dire
mais c'est un grade d'étudiants quoi
donc un étudiant en chimie quoi
à qui tu demandes voilà
ce sont les seuls avec un cinquième
doigt qu'est ce que tu racontes alors
d'une c'est la meuf qu'est ce que tu
racontes
et le mec qui l'interrogent c'est
pourquoi tu as gardé sa ba je sais
pourquoi il a gardé sa el dine énorme
connerie et lui sait ce qu'il veut c'est
entendre des gens qui disent d énorme
connerie donc encore une fois
malhonnêteté dans le montage
et les koalas ils ont deux doigts ou les
âmes ce qu'elle voulait dire c'est qu'on
a un pouce opposable mais les koalas ils
ont deux doigts opposable s'aperçoit
qu'en descente
[Musique]
c'est le principe du chaînon manquant
c'est qu'on n'a pas trouvé
voilà les experts l'ont dit et j'ai
confiance dans les experts malade enfin
qui emploie le mot trust enfin quelqu'un
qui employait le mot trust exactement
exactement le flou qui apparaît trop
tard c'est magnifique le montage
le flou de visages qui laisse apparaître
le visage pendant 2 secondes et qui le
foot après je ne sais pas pourquoi la
beauté de ce montage voilà c'est
probablement un flou qui est apparu plus
tard sur la vidéo j'imagine que c'est un
flou ça a flu rajouter sur youtube en
fait comme comme jdg il fait quand
il est censuré
bon enfin quelqu'un qui emploie le mot
trust confiance la confiance envers les
scientifiques et envers les preuves
voilà ça c'est quelqu'un il lui a
répondu du tac au tac il est resté à
l'écran 4 secondes
évidemment tu prends un étudiant
évidemment qui va te répondre
alors là encore une fois faith le mot
faith la fois on les experts pas là
pas la confiance bien que il est traduit
la part le mot confiance ce qui est à
mon avis une erreur
mais ce qui m'arrange voilà c'est la
confiance
il faut dire aussi que j'ai j'ai un
petit problème avec cette direction que
prend le
micro trottoir là maintenant c'est qu'en
fait il va donc essayer de nous dire que
la croyance en l'évolution est une
croyance une croyance religieuse
est ce qu'il y a de bizarre c'est que du
coup ben ça veut dire ça veut dire
qu'une croyance religieuse c'est mal
mais en même temps c'est une vidéo que
tu fais pour convaincre les gens de pas
être ratée
c est ce que est ce que votre démarche
ne serait pas un peu d'eau hbe du cul
ce que serait pas un peu de bide du plu
de base
elle est c'est une question rhétorique
bien entendu
voilà des experts serviette oui c'est
définitivement un montage d'après sur
youtube
voilà la génétique
voilà une preuve basé sur la génétique
se trouve
donc vous voyez le changement de genre
c'est un truc c'est un accordéon en fait
c'est un mot accordéon c'est à dire que
on lui dit il dit montrez-moi un
changement de caïds de genre et tu lui
dis bien regarder ces espèces elles ont
changé au travers du temps ouais mais
c'est toujours des poissons bah oui ils
vont pas se transformer en papillon
c'est pas des pokémon
le dire bon bah tu veux un changement de
kind et bien prenons les sarcomes terry
gien les poissons sarko pts et régions
donc sarko pts et rivières
évolution voilà et puis tu prends les
sarko terry gien ou sarcopte origines si
tu veux le nom scientifique ça me va ça
n'a pas donc les sarko pts est rien ce
sont ces fameux poisson sarko fait rien
qu'ils sont devenus des tétrapodes le
plus le plus brillant exemple étant
évidemment tiktaalik
donc qui a un corps de poisson avec des
nageoires de avec des nageoires de
ma part donc il ya un corps de poisson
avec des pâtes des pâtes de tétrapodes
donc voilà c'est cette fameuse
transformation dont on a beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de représentants
fossiles
encore que là dans celle là c'est la
phylogénie ddc là quand est ce que vous
allez me mettre un bon exemple bon bref
vous avez cette image qui est très
connue évidemment c'est celle voilà deux
de la transition de la mer à la terre
avec certaines options tiktaalik ict ios
dégâts moi j'aime bien montrer lepisto
steger parce que lepisto steger c'est
mon préféré et que vous le savez
elles pisto steger dont on voit
directement sur l'image est pas il n'y a
pas énormément d' analyse à faire sur la
piste au stage et c'est pour ça que je
les aime beaucoup c'est une image qui
parle d'elle-même en fait les pistes
hausse tg il a un corps de poisson voyez
c'est un corps couvert des cayes il a
les nageoires on voit tout les nageoires
très avec des avec des rayons voilà il a
un corps de poisson sauf que sa tête
c'est une tête d'amphibiens il a une
tête d'amphibiens avec des yeux placé
sur le sommet du crâne comme un échec
bien une tête toute plate comme un
amphibien notamment les amphibiens du
permien qui ont une tête toute plate
comme ça il a les épaules enfin il a les
opercules séparée du corps donc les
épaules il a des épaules parce que les
opercules séparée du corps c'est ça qui
se transforme en et en ceinture
scapulaire en épaules donc il a des
épaules et à la place du coup d
opercules donc là où il y avait des
branchies baïla ce qu'on appelle des
encoches aux tic c'est à dire des
oreilles voilà il n'avait pas des
oreilles avec des sur la tête comme un
charme et julien il a des oreilles il
avait un tympan et il parle ça lui
permettait d'entendre à l'air libre
après il ya des théories qui disent que
ce serait juste un inspira khl qui lui
permettait de respirer aussi en l'air ce
que je trouve un peu inutile si là il
avait des narines aussi qui sortait de
l'eau donc bon mais voilà il ya 2 il ya
deux théories on va dire mais quoi qu'il
arrive c'est un truc qui est là parce
que il vivait à la fois dans l'eau et à
l'air libre voilà donc on est sur un
truc qui vit à la fois dans l'eau et à
l'air libre et qu'il ya un corps de
poisson avec une tête d'amphibiens
chaînon manquant ma gueule chaînon
manquant
et là vous voyez le fossile donc preuve
que je ne mens pas
voilà c'est on l'a à cette
transformation c'est un trans c'est une
transformation depuis les poissons voyez
c'était donc les ronces est
définitivement un poisson jusqu'à
jusqu'au tétrapodes avec tous les
chaînons manquants entre les deux de
moins en moins de poissons de plus en
plus amphibiens jusqu'à à l'animal
qu'ils étaient capables de vivre sur
terre alors ils tirent stega était pas
tout à fait capables de vivre sur terre
tu l'erp et ont par contre lui il
l'était
voilà
mais évidemment évidemment encore une
fois été interrogé pendant un
micro-trottoir tu les trouves où ces
images tuer puis de toute façon même si
tu veux aller chercher sur ton téléphone
est ce qu'il va les garder à son sur son
truc bien évidemment
au sens phylogénétique oui le son c'est
encore une fois il ne le dit pas
vous sentez comme il est agacé aussi
l'alleud le mec vous sentez comme il est
agacé par les questions évidemment que
les êtres humains sont des poissons mais
au sens philosophique du terme
on avait les deux on avait les deux
femmes n'ont
tiktaalik avec les deux tiktaalik il
avait encore les opercules donc c'est
tiktaalik il est un cran avoir une piste
ho steger dictée non c'est pas tiktaalik
panda vectis pendent erik thysse il est
un cran avant ils pistent steger et
tiktaalik du coup
bon derrick tice et il a encore des
opercules
où est ce qu'on va trouver une bonne
image dans l'autre sens cette image est
bien suffisante voilà vous voyez les
opercules sont encore attachés au crâne
ce qui veut dire qu'en dessous il y
avait des branchies par contre dans d
haïti s'il a le crâne plat
il a le crâne plat il allait d'un joueur
bien charnues qui lui permettait quand
même de se traîner au sol et il a des
causes internes ce qui montre donc c'est
à dire que les trous du nez au lieu de
se ré ouvrir à l'extérieur s'ouvre vers
l'intérieur de la bouche ce qui veut
dire aussi qu'il y avait des poumons
parce qu' aucun intérêt à avoir des
causes internes si vous n'avez pas des
poumons donc donc pandémique this avait
à la fois des poumons est débranché mais
bon encore faut-il le savoir et encore
faut-il que ça vous viennent à l'esprit
quand un crétin vous pose ça dans la
question dans la rue au pif
voilà il y en avoir il là vous voyez
comment il l'a eu il l'a eu en lui
faisant admettre qu'il ne savait pas
exactement mais en même temps tu
demandes adhérents de dôme dans la rue
si saab a évidemment qu'ils savent pas
évidemment
changement ouais toujours la subtilité
sur le changement de cannes je vais pas
arrêter la vidéo à chaque fois qu'il
prononce le mot kind je pense que vous
avez compris l'idée il ya juste une
énorme flux sur la
c'est à dire ça c'est typiquement le
genre de créationnistes à qui tu rentres
tu montres du coup l'évolution et le mec
qui te réponds bah attendez votre cheval
votre cheval ne s'est pas transformé en
finale batroun voyons
bah oui mais si vous me trouvez un
exemple en fait c'est ça le truc c'est
qu'il faut penser à répondre que mais si
on voyait un cheval se transformer en
albatros alors la théorie de l'évolution
serait fausse totalement
absolument parce que ce serait de la
magie et la magie effectivement c'est
dieu c'est dieu qui fait de la magie non
nous on pense pas que la magie existe
nous en tant que scientifique on ne
pense pas que la magie existe on pense
que les espèces évoluent lentement très
lentement et que ces changements de
caïds dont il parle c'est changement de
genre auront lieu sur un temps tellement
long et de façon tellement
dissipe et qu'on les verrait pas se
produire en fait c'est ça le truc c'est
qu'on ne s'en rendrait pas compte même
dans les voyants en fait on s'en
rendrait pas compte c'est à dire que le
tiktaalik se rendait pas compte qu'ils
étaient en train de se transformer en
autre chose qu'un poisson et pourtant
après des millions d'années ça a donné
vie aux dégâts qui n'était déjà plus un
poisson qui avait quatre pattes mais le
tiktaalik c'était un poisson mais ils
avaient déjà beaucoup de
caractéristiques de ses descendants à
quatre pattes que sont la tête plate les
yeux sommet de la tête les opercules
séparé du crâne et après lepisto steger
en plus ajouter des doigts donc il avait
des grosses nageoires bien charnue avec
des eaux dedans il a rajouté des petite
phalange et après il ya encore eu
l'ajout de
surtout eu des retirages eu surtout eu
des retirages leurs tirages des rayons
des nageoires rayon des nageoires qui
sont perdus chez xo stega mais qui sont
encore présentes sur sa queue et après
haïti au steak house avait la perte des
rayons des nageoires sur la que
l'acquisition d'une mobilité des pâtes
qui permet de se mouvoir sur terre qui
enfin fait de fait que nous en tant
qu'être humain a posteriori on puisse
appliquer notre grosse vision is
essentialiste du monde et tracer une
limite en disant ça c'est un tétrapodes
ça c'est un poisson voilà
et je rappelle que la limite entre le
poisson et le tétrapodes est tellement
fine ça tient au doigt en fait là on a
un registre fossile qui est tellement
bien documenté la cette transition et
ben voilà parfait un jeu j'ai retrouvé
l'image enfin j'ai trouvé une image
parfaitement illustratif de ce phénomène
voilà la transformation justement d'une
nageoire de poissons à une patte de
tétrapodes elle est tellement bien
documenté elle est tellement documenté
par plane fossiles qui a fini par on a
fini par tracer une limite absolument
arbitraire entre les deux qui est
l'apparition des doigts l'apparition des
phalanges dans quelles pistes au steger
que je vous ai montré tout à l'heure
avec son corps de poisson
sa tête de d'amphibiens techniquement
parlant c'est un tétrapodes donc c'est
un changement de carried d'après ce
créationnistes elle piste au cg est un
changement de kaïn l'apparition de ces
phalanges fait de lui un nouveau un
nouveau genre dans le sens où lui
l'entente voilà fait de lui une nouvelle
nouveau pas une vel étage je sais pas
comment vous pourriez dire dans
l'évolution voiliers mais c'est cette
évolution l'asi tout ça c'est
l'illustration de fossiles qui existe un
e sténose theron pendent erik thysse
elle piste host et j'ai outils cta à
licques parce que là sans les fossiles
je peux pas faire la différence
personnellement ça ça doit être ici
aussi tes gars a quant aux dégâts à mon
avis c'est un canton cité gaza c'est ict
y aussi des gars et ça ça doit être
claire petton et voyez la transition
elle est tellement fine tellement douce
vaincu il a fallu tracer une limite
arbitraire
voilà tellement bien documenté qu'il
faut tracer une limite arbitraire et
évidemment sans support visuel et en
rendent improvisation c'est pas évident
a raconté comme l'histoire
mais c'est pareil là il veut il veut en
gros un unicellulaires qui deviendrait
un multicellulaires mais ça on en a des
unicellulaires qui se transforme en
multi singulair on a des néo l'économie
la gêne et notamment l'écho anneaux
flageller sont capables de se regrouper
et formé à partir des êtres
unicellulaires former un être
multicellulaires donc si vous cherchez
l'écho anneaux flageller je suis sûr que
qu à nos fleurs je les vois la bête
je suis sûr que c'est la première
illustration que vous allez trouver
d'écho and of la jebba voyez déco
anneaux flageller tout seul voilà
qui se balade tout seul et décors enough
l'algérie qui se baladent en
multicellulaires donc l'écho à neauphle
à gênés ils sont capables de le travail
est à la fois en unicellulaires et en
multicellulaires c'est un changement de
genre selon ce qu'ils nous demandent
voilà
vous voyez là il est en train de
s'engueuler parce que l'autre il a enfin
compris qu'il essaye de le rouler dans
la phase aller en train de rouler dans
la farine
il ya 14 définition de l'espèce il a
probablement raison du coup moi je vous
demande un truc qui a rien à voir
[Rires]
voilà donc il est en train de lui dire
valeur vous êtes en train de vous
demander de vous n'êtes pas en train de
me demander de l'évolution darwinienne
vous êtes en train de me demander une
évolution pokémon
c'est si si un changement de kind comme
le mec le réconforte veut en entendre un
existait réellement bas la théorie de
l'évolution darwinienne ne marcherait
pas parce que c'est pas comme ça que
fonctionne l'évolution darwinienne ça
c'est un truc qu'ils ont du mal à
imprimer les créationnistes mais en plus
la lasser même pas c'est même pas une
question en est en fait c'est une
question malhonnête il est là pour les
piéger mais peut-être vous y attendez il
à disneyland de mec dont il est vraiment
aller lui casser les noyaux à disneyland
pendant ce week end
a été utilisé le mot croyances arrêtée
de tomber dans le piège en fait
voilà en train de patauger y patauge il
patauge mayday mayday mayday
et ça y est il est tombé dans ce piège
il est complètement tombé dans un piège
et voilà il a marché deux pieds dedans
ça y est il a eu il a remplacé confiance
par croyance
personnes darwin exemple un peu usée
jusqu'à la corde ils ont pu véhiculer
c'est pas pareil ce n'est pas un super
bon exemple d'autant que la plupart des
gens ne le connaissent pas bien cet
exemple en réalité ne connaissent très
très mal même
alors que alors que si tu alors que si
tu prenais un autre exemple genre balles
et les pingouins et je dis bien les
pingouins et pas les manchots c'est à
dire ce qu'on appelle réellement des
pingouins les pingouins sont des animaux
volants voilà
donc
va te faire [ __ ] ça voyez ça
donc ça voilà ne plus confondre ça c'est
un manchot exactement exactement donc et
ça par contre c'est un pingouin
effectivement et donc les pingouins
contrairement aux manchots savent voler
les pingouins vol les pingouins sont des
oiseaux volants qui vivent dans
l'hémisphère nord contrairement manchots
qui sont des animaux non volantes qui
vivent dans l'hémisphère sud bon et bien
chez les pingouins on a donc une grande
diversité d'espèces volantes et ensuite
on a le grand pingouin le grand pingouin
qui lui étaient par contre une espèce
qui nageait qui était exclusivement
nageuse dont les ailes était trop petite
pour pouvoir voler et donc ça ça aussi
ça correspond à un changement de kind
dans son dans son registre parce que
pour lui on passe d'une espèce qui vole
à une espèce qui nage voilà ça à la
limite ce sera un bon exemple pas les
pinsons de darwin
c'est là en fait tu limite plus en train
de débloquer les argumentaires toury les
gens qui se font
c'est surtout pour montrer qu'en fait
ces questions sont malhonnêtes et sont
mal posée en fait ces questions sont
d'une valeur nette est mal peau
voilà il est fait se perdre dans les
dents les passantes darwin parce qu'il
sait que les gens vont se perdre dans
les pins centre darwin parce qu'ils ne
connaissent pas cet exemple ont
correctement au lieu de prendre des
vrais bons exemples
donc là c'est le regard que vous faites
c'est le regard que vous faites ça
ça le regarde quand tu fais quand tu
comprends que le mec qu'elle veut une
évolution pokémon au lieu d'une
évolution darwinienne
là est là tu dis mais jamais je peux te
donner ça évidemment que je peux pas
donner ça je peux pas te le donner
puisque si je te le donne est ça
voudrait dire que l'évolution
darwinienne ne marche pas donc je peux
pas vu qu'elle marche à
pourquoi il ya une scène de crime
derrière lui je n'avais pas noté à webo
il demande à un géologue
enfin j'ai énormément de respect pour
mes collègues géologue mais mes
collègues géologues sont généralement
enfin je veux dire la seule discipline
de la géologie qui se rapproche de la
paléontologie c'est la sédimentologie
alors à moins que vous soyez
sédimentologue il n'y a pas de raison
que vous ayez fréquenté énormément de
fossiles et donc que vous ayez fréquenté
la théorie de l'évolution
je veux dire y'a pas donc c'est pour ça
que je dis vous posez la question à un
géologue oui c'est comme poser la
question à un chimiste ou un point ou un
physicien le dior il n'y a pas de raison
qu un géologue a été confronté plus que
ça la théorie de l'évolution les à moins
qu'il soit sera versé dans la
stratigraphie et dans ce cas là il est
en contact des fossiles et même là ça
veut pas dire qu'il a besoin de
connaître la théorie de l'évolution
jeudi à un hydrogéologue qui travaille
sur les systèmes aquatiques sur les
karsts un
géophysicien le dire qu' un géophysicien
qui passent littéralement sa vie à faire
des calculs
c'est ça les géophysiciens le n'y a
aucune raison qu'ils aient entendre
qu'ils aient à fréquenter la théorie de
l'évolution alors tu demandes à un
géologue en croyant m'impressionner tu
ne m'impressionne pas
vous remarqué à quel point role of
sciences est bien représenté derrière et
magnifiquement dans le cadre c'est pour
bien montrer que voilà le grand temple
de la science se dresse derrière ce
monsieur et il est incapable de répondre
à ma question c'est la mise en scène
aussi elle est intéressante elle est
intéressante et fallacieuse c'est à dire
que vous voyez ce monsieur parle devant
le grand temple de la science parce que
je vous rappelle que son propos c'est
quand même de nous dire que là que la
science est une croyance comme une autre
un physicien on l'a pourquoi tu nous
montres à physicien le dire le physicien
qu'est ce qui va en savoir
qu'est ce qu'ils vont en savoir ces gens
ils peuvent rien savoir c'est pas leur
domaine de spécialité
voilà donc le grand temple de la science
est une science corrompus qui n'est pas
capable de répondre à vos questions bah
oui mais tu demandes à des étudiants à
la sortie des classes de l'université
parce que c'est exactement ce qu'il est
en train de faire évidemment qu'ils vont
pas savoir te répondre ce n'est pas leur
métier de savoir te répondre demande à
aaron rathy un mec qui s'est spécialisé
dans le débat une cage l'apologie de
chrétiens
là par contre tu vas en chier chaîne que
je recommande d'ailleurs la chaîne de
aaron rats
aller voir si vous aimez enfin si vous
connaissez l'anglais évidemment et que
vous aimez les mecs qui défonce du
créationnistes au petit matin
l'huile et défonce toutes les semaines
toutes les semaines vous avez une
nouvelle vidéo il défense du
créationnisme
c'est son métier c'est ce qui fait c'est
comme ça qui gagne sa vie le mec qui
défonce des créationnistes alors lui par
contre il le croise dans un miroir un
micro trottoir et conforte mais alors il
le démontre à l'argumentaire quoi ce que
je vous assure que il est illégal et les
télés
bah voilà ça y est il a réussi à obtenir
ce qu'il voulait là
il a fini par trouver suffisamment de
gens au pif qui était pas qui était
capable de leur dire tout ce qu'ils
voulaient en fait tout ce qu'il voulait
ça y est là il a atteint le point le
fameux point qu'il voulait atteindre
c'est donc il a trouvé des gens qui
croient en l'évolution pas qu'ils
pensent que l'évolution est vrai il a
trouvé des gens qui sont capables de lui
dire je crois en l'évolution il lui a
demandé montrez-moi des preuves les gens
sont incapables de produire des preuves
parce que évidemment ils ne les
connaissent pas ces preuves il pense les
avoir vus en cours ils les ont vus
probablement en cours à l'école à la fac
ou je ne sais quoi mais ils ne sont pas
capables de les expliquer de façon
convaincante parce que c'est pas leur
métier c'est pas leur spécialité y voit
là ils ont une connaissance
superficielle de l'évolution ils savent
que ça existe et c'est tout ce qu'on
leur demande de savoir et c'est normal
donc une fois qu'il a obtenu 2 que
qu'elles ont admis
qu'ils ne connaissent pas l'évolution
afin qu'ils ne peuvent pas produire de
preuve de l'évolution là il a atteint
voilà à la 13e minute je rappelle que
c'est le 13ème dble kg pénitence
l'avant-dernier 13e minute du 13ème dble
kg pénitence coïncidence j'en doute
coïncidence rigolote mais quand les
pitres pose une
donc à la 13e minute
il déclare mais si vous croyez en
l'évolution et qu'il n'y a pas de preuve
l'évolution n'est pas une science et oui
s'il n'y a pas de preuve c'est pas une
science
sauf que tout ce que tu as démontré
jusqu'à présent c'est non l'évolution
les gens connaissent pas les preuves
c'est tout ce que tu sais tout ce que tu
démontres avec un micro trottoir c'est
que les gens ne savent pas ne sont pas
capables de répondre à tes questions ça
veut pas dire qu'il ya pas de réponses à
tes questions
si je demande à ce monsieur quelle est
la console la constante de bord voilà
donnez moi la constante de bord s'il
vous plaît et le monsieur me répond la
constante de quoi vous voyez la
constante de bord n'existe pas
je ne sais même pas si elle existe à
cette constante de borges jeudi au pif a
récité mois pige jusqu'à la 112e
décimales
j'en suis incapable adoncques qui
n'existe pas
c'est exactement ce qu'il vient de faire
est ce que vous croyez au nombre pi oui
j'y crois est ce que vous êtes capable
de me réciter pige jusqu'à la 112e
décimales
non alors pis n'existe pas qui n'est pas
scientifique
non tu as seulement démontré que j'étais
pas capable de réciter pige jusqu'à la
112e décima tu as juste tu as juste
démontrer que des gens pris au pif à la
sortie d'un d'une fac de sciences
ne sont pas capable de te réciter des
preuves de l'évolution comme comme un
spécialiste des
j'ai même envie de dire c'est même pas
un scientifique
c'est pas un scientifique qui se révèle
incapable de donner une liste de toutes
ces preuves
c'est comme j'ai dit c'est un mec comme
aaron rimbaud dont le métier est de
contrecarrer des arguments
créationnistes c'est c'est la seule
personne qui est capable de te
millefeuille argumentative est à face
pour que tu la fermes et si une telle
personne et si tu avais croisé une telle
personne à la sortie de ton rôle de
sciences la all signs et bien tu
l'aurais coupée au montage et je suis
sûr que tu l'as fait
et voilà il a réussi à obtenir ce qu'ils
voulaient bien bienvenue dans bienvenue
dans le grand monde de la malhonnêteté
intellectuelle il a réussi à obtenir que
des étudiants lui dise je sais pas
l'épreuve donc ça n'existe pas
je rappelle aussi que c'est comme ça que
fonctionne la complexité irréductible à
l'argument comme quoi le flagelle est
trop complexe et
donc il a forcément été créé c'est
exactement comme ça qui fonctionne c'est
trop compliqué ne comprend pas alors ça
n'existe pas voilà
c'est trop compliqué ne comprend pas
alors ça a été créé voilà
donc c'est les créationnistes aime
beaucoup ce genre de raisonnement le
genre de raisonnement qui est je
comprends pas donc ça n'existe pas il ne
comprend pas donc c'est dieu qui l'a
fait donc c'est comme ça qu'ils font
avec le flagelle c'est comme ça qu'ils
font avec
c'est comme ça qu'ils font avec l'adn
aussi l'adn c'est trop compliqué alors
c'est dieu qui l'a créé un buzz les gens
par le mail l'existence de la rn
oublié l'existence de la rn arn qui est
la preuve que l'adn n'est pas sortie de
nulle part parce que la reine ne sert à
rien c'est une étape surnuméraires dans
la dans la traduction de l'adn pourquoi
ne traduis ton pas l'adn directement
réponse l'adn a une longue histoire une
longue histoire évolutive qui a impliqué
à un moment qui eut la rn mais bref la
fois
acropole cobalt de m excuse twilight 2
need to find évaluer est évidente ouais
bah évidemment richard dawkins
probablement dans
la désillusion de dieu enfin the gods
diluviennes qui dit que la fois c'est
pas bien la fois celle excuse pour
éviter d'avoir à penser de façon
critique c'est une analyse richard
dawkins 1 j'ai envie de dire c'est une
analyse un peu brut de décoffrage et pas
très profonde
c'est de l'anti apologétique un peu un
peu de surface
évidemment ils ont pris une phrase qui
est volontairement provocatrice pour
dire aux gens vous voyez c'est de la foi
aveugle et richard dawkins il a dit la
foi aveugle c'était pas bien et
l'évolution c'est de la foi aveugle
c'est pas bien
vous vous êtes fait avoir à votre propre
jeu évolutionniste ce que la regarder
combien des évolutionnistes et un à deux
ans il ya le monsieur barbu là et
l'autre monsieur dans le bureau il y en
a que deux des vrais évolutionniste des
gens qui travaillent sur l'évolution
dans le temps et comme j'ai dit les a
chopé par surprise et il leur pose des
questions qui n'ont pas de réponse donc
il leur pose des questions pièges
donc évidemment qu'il obtient exactement
ce qu'ils faisaient
il aurait fait ça avec richard dawkins
typiquement alors ils se seraient fait
poutrer mais il va pas aller voir
richard dawkins puisque richard dawkins
est connu et il saura lui réponde parce
que richard dawkins il sait les réponses
à toutes ces questions merde
vie en rose alors là ils leur demandent
s'ils peuvent créer
leur demande s'ils peuvent générer une
rose ou un grain de sable de rien donc
je m'aime moi je comprends pas où il
essaye d'aller pourtant là je depuis
tout à l'heure je devine assez bien le
faire ici il va vers le dessein
intelligent de n'êtes vous pas capable
de créer une rose banon et pourquoi
parce que je ne suis pas je suis capable
de
l'a77 dames la réponse qu'elles
devraient donner la cette dame c'est non
je ne suis pas capable de créer un grain
de sable et je suis pas capable de créer
une rose par contre je peux créer un
être humain
c'est une femme elle à un utérus elle
est capable de générer un petit être
humain est ce que ça fait de moi dieu ou
à l'interrogation est là il est cassé le
mec
là le mec il est détruit là mais oui
enfin je veux dire je j'imagine bien que
cette question de est ce que vous êtes
capable de créer une rose de nulle part
ou un grain de sable de nulle part va
va conduire à une autre question qui est
censé vous conduire à dire le dessein
intelligent bah oui c'est vrai mais
pourquoi
pour pourquoi partir sur pour sur cette
question assez bizarre en fait pourquoi
passer du temps même sur cette question
là en fait moi je l'aurais même limite
coupée au montage
pourquoi
c'est pour ça c'est pour parler de
l'éducation de l'intelligent design donc
et là en plus il fait un aparté vous
voyez il a brisé la règle du
micro-trottoir maintenant pour nous
faire un exposé
c'était vraiment juste pour prendre ce
petit détour nous expliquait alors
pourquoi le dessein intelligent n'est
pas enseignée dans les écoles la réponse
est en tout cas aux états unis parce que
il ya eu ce fameux procès
enfin entre autres ce fameux procès qui
a démontré qu'en fait c'était non
constitutionnels de d'enseignés autre
chose que la théorie de l'évolution en
fait ces dons constitutionnel
d'enseigner une théorie qui inclut des
croyances à des des croyances
religieuses en fait c'est ça le truc c
chacun est libre de pratiquer la
religion qu'il veut et donc enfin si
j'ai bien suivi évidemment je suis pas
un expert en loi américaine donc corrigé
mois dans les commentaires évidemment
mais si j'ai bien compris l'idée c'est
qu'en gros
le dessein intelligent impose
impose en fait une croyance à la
religion chrétienne parce que le dessein
intelligent est étroitement liée à la
religion chrétienne la religion
chrétienne est à peu près la seule qui
propose une théorie du dessein
intelligent donc le dessein intelligent
est étroitement liée à la religion
chrétienne et du coup imposer le dessein
intelligent à l'école c'est aussi
imposer la religion chrétienne ce qui
est contraire il me semble à l'un des
amendements enfin bref à la constitution
américaine qui dit qu' on a la liberté
de religion voilà
aux états unis il me semble que c'est ça
mais bref la raison pour laquelle c'est
pas de toute façon la raison principale
pour laquelle ces prêts dans les écoles
c'est parce que à partir du moment où il
ya un grand être magique qui fait des
choses c'est juste pas de la science un
point c'est tout donc que ce grand être
magique soit un être super
technologiques comme des extraterrestres
parce que le dessein intelligent vous
avez aussi des gens qui disent que le
les gens ont été fabriqués par des
extraterrestres scientologie par exemple
donc vous avez le dessein intelligent
qui inclut des extraterrestres et vous
avez déjà deux genres la scientologie et
vous avez le dessin est intelligente qui
fait appel à dieu
mais à partir du moment où vous avez un
truc surnaturel dans l'équation c'est à
dire un truc dont on ne peut pas fournir
la preuve de l'existence ou de la non
existence
dont la nature même j'ai envie de dire
dans le cadre dans le cas de dieu en
plus c'est la nature même de ce qu'il
devrait être exclu totalement con
puissant prouver l'existence ou la non
existence donc
voilà donc à partir du moment où vous
avez eu un truc comme ça dans votre
théorie votre théorie elle pue du cul
voilà lé nom scientifique
donc c'est pour ça surtout qu'elle n'est
pas enseignée
voilà c'est exactement ce que je vous
disais je suis content une fois je pas
dit une connerie
[Rires]
alors
là il donne nous faire du coup la
résumer
le résumé moisi le résumé pourri de
l'évolution depuis enfin de l'évolution
de l'univers jusqu'à l'apparition de la
rose du coût et de la girafe et du
cheval comme il dit
donc il ya eu une grosse explosion et
des roses et des chevaux oui
enfin déjà on est tous d'accord pour
dire que le big bang n'était pas une
explosion on est tous d'accord que ça
inclut des milliards et des milliards
d'années de fusion et de fission
nucléaire donc je suis incapable de vous
expliquer le fonctionnement 1 mais il ya
des physiciens qui sont capables de le
faire
et puis ça inclut ensuite l'apparition
de la vie qui n'est pas du domaine de
l'e la théorie de l'évolution de la
théorie de l'évolution je le rappelle
c'est la théorie qui explique l'origine
de la biodiversité et non pas l'origine
de la vie l'origine de la vie c'est
quelque chose qui en revient aux
biochimiste pas aux biologistes de
l'évolution donc mais l'origine de la
vie la vie il faut arrêter d'imaginer ça
en fait et encore une fois on en revient
au concept de karine
la vie faut arrêter d'imaginer ça comme
un phénomène surnaturel
c'est pas un phénomène surnaturel la vie
la vie c'est quelque chose qu'on arrive
a expliqué à l'échelle atomique
comme d une série de réactions chimiques
et c'est tout le fonctionnement de votre
cerveau c'est des potentiels d'action
potentiel d'action qui sont ni plus ni
moins que de l'électricité donc dû à des
transfert d'électrons transfert
d'électrons dont on sait exactement où
quand et comment ils ont lieu grâce au
pop à protons machin enfin bref je vous
renvoie à vos cours de neurophysiologie
si vous en avez eu et je vous renvoie à
des cours de neurophysiologie si vous
n'en avez pas eu la neurophysiologie
mambo vous pouvez me citer si vous le
voulez la neurophysiologie vous êtes un
prof de neurophysiologie pourrait citer
la neuro fusionner mambo la
neurophysiologie basiquement ce qui vous
démontre que la vie n'a rien de spécial
c'est de la biochimie la vis et de la
biochimie c'est une biochimiques et
[ __ ] de compliqué
qui est [ __ ] de compliqué qui
fonctionne dans beaucoup de direction
tout en même temps et que et qui
fonctionne tout en même temps par des
chaînes de réaction extrêmement
intriqués à produire ce phénomène que
nous êtres humains avec notre cerveau
essentialiste dégueulasse je le rappelle
appelons la vie et considérons comme
magique ce qu'il n'est pas la vie n'est
pas magique c'est de la biochimie et on
peut complètement descendre tous les
fonctions tout ce que tout ce qui
fonctionne dans notre dans notre
organisme peut être expliquée au niveau
moléculaire
par des réactions chimiques
et des potentiels d'action donc des
échanges d'électrons et de protons et
les bref des
justes de l'électricité quoi de
l'électricité générée chimiquement
encore une fois donc des réactions
chimiques j'en reviens à mon truc tout
ce qui se passe dans notre corps peut
être expliquée au niveau chimiques de
façon très simple
notre corps c'est juste une grosse
réaction chimique c'est une énorme
réaction chimique mais ça n'est que de
la chimie de la chimie qui existe par
ailleurs qu'on appelle de la biochimiste
chimie
c'est de la chimie des molécules
biologiques
voilà c'est tout c'est de l'habillage
est la meilleure la meilleure raison
pour dire que la vie n'est rien d'autre
qu'un phénomène chimique qui a pris des
proportions gigantesques mais qui a
commencé de façon très très simple dans
une soupe primitive et bah c'est juste
que c'est toujours le cas aujourd'hui la
vie c'est toujours une énorme réaction
chimique c'est juste une réaction
chimique un point c'est tout fait avec
des éléments chimiques qui n'existe pas
ailleurs
voilà
c'est simple je veux dire c'est ya pas
deux il n'y a pas d'explication magique
la vie si la vie était vraiment le
produit d'une création y'a rien qui
l'empêcherait d'être des trappes à base
de je sais pas moi de truc qui n'existe
pas ailleurs
pourquoi la vie doit être fait des mêmes
atom que le reste pourquoi si le vivant
est exceptionnel si le vivant et
d'essence divine pourquoi est il fait
des mêmes atom que le reste
il n'y a pas de raison il ya même plein
de raisons pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'ait
pas fait de magie je veux dire voilà
parce que dieu est parce que dieu est
contenue dans l'est par les lois de la
physique dieu il est pas contenue par
les lois de la physique dieu il crée les
lois de la physique
il est pas il n'est pas limité par les
lois de la physique dieu c'est lui qui
les fait donc sinon il n'est pas dieu
donc
[Musique]
pourquoi ne sommes nous pas magique je
veux dire pourquoi ne sommes nous pas
tellement magique qu'on s'en rendrait
compte jeudi en masse
donc nous sommes fait des mêmes atom que
le reste nous sommes fait nous sommes
fait des mêmes molécule biochimique et 7
biochimie lcl se lit encore à
l'intérieur de nous je veux dire vous
regardez le fonctionnement du cerveau
c'est des réactions chimiques qui génère
des potentiels d'action quelque chose
qu'on peut tout à fait voir
y'a pas de cesser de la physique de
barrage c'est de la physique compliqué
face et la physique et de la chimie
compliqué mais ça reste que de la
physique et la chimie et ça se comprend
très bien et on comprend très bien
comment ça a pu apparaître à partir de
rien ça s'appelle la théorie de la bio
jeunesse comprends très bien comment une
soupe peut devenir ça avec avec la pluie
encore une fois de variations aléatoires
et de sélection naturelle
regardez regardez la tête du minho
regardez la tête du minho il a quel âge
là 21 ans je veux dire c'est ces salles
autorités que tu nous présentes
je veux dire encore une fois je tout le
respect de toute façon maintenant il
doit être je pense pas qu'en 2013
j'avais moins l'air jeune que ça mais
c'est la vidéo date quand même de 2013
mais mais voilà c'est ça ton autorité
que tu nous prends ses amis nos me dire
il va nous chercher un minot à la sortie
de l'amphi elodie est tu crois en
l'évolution non enfin tu crois en
l'évolution oui ah t'es con
[Rires]
qu'est-ce que tu essayes de prouver ça
je vois bien ce que tu essaies de
prouvais mais je veux pas comment les
gens peuvent se faire piéger par sa
enfin comment tu peux faire piéger par
ça
l organe relictuelle ils appellent ça un
résiduel et il est débile
de l'ict vestiges earl wayne geste idiot
le président hu
l'appendice à un rôle alors il a ça
c'est pareil c'est la fameuse théorie du
tout adaptatif l'appendice sylla panis
existe il a forcément un rôle non pas
forcément et c'est pas parce que vous
avez trouvé un rôle à l'appendice que
c'est pour ça qu'il existe c'est surtout
ça le corollaire c'est à dire que tout
ce qui existe n'a pas forcément un rôle
on a ce qu'on appelle la sélection
neutre donc qui est la non sélection
naturelle en fait ni pour ni contre donc
il ya des organes qui reste sans être
contre sélectionné juste parce qu'ils
sont neutres et on a aussi des de
l'évolution non adaptative comme par
exemple la dérive génétique et tout ce
qui est contrainte génétiques quand par
exemple vous avez un organe enfin quand
vous avez un gène très délétère attaché
à un gène qui est très utile ça va être
très difficile un mini je veux dire
quand ils sont physiquement attaché sur
le chromosome l'un à l'autre ça va être
très difficile de se débarrasser du gnv
les terres sans se débarrasser du gène
du gène qui est qui lui par contre un
fort rôle adaptatif ce qui fait que vous
finissez avec un gène délétère au final
mais ça on en parle très bien dans notre
vidéo sur la mort pourquoi meurt-on
entracte science voilà vous gueulez en
tracts aux sciences pourquoi meurt-on et
vous allez trouvez vous allez trouver
notre vidéo où là on vous explique en
long en large et en travers ben pourquoi
au final la mort est darwinienne
la mort est extrêmement darwinienne il
n'y a pas de raison pour laquelle on ne
sera pas immortel si on est une création
divine 1 ça aussi c'est un autre exemple
c'est essayer aussi une des réponses
tout bête que vous pouvez donner un jour
à un créationniste si on vous demande
vous croyant l'évolution pourquoi
l'épreuve va parce qu'on meurt
parce qu'on meurt et que et que si dieu
nous avait créé bas il n'y a pas de
raison pour qu'on meurt
donnez moi une raison pour laquelle on
devrait mourir pour laisser de la place
pour les générations suivantes bas dieu
dans sa grande sagesse aurait pu nous
empêcher de nous reproduire
et puis voilà je veux dire il nous place
là et puis on vit notre vie et puis
voilà
et c'est tout
c'est jeudi il n'y a pas de raison pour
laquelle on devrait se reproduire s'il
ya une raison spécifique pour laquelle
dieu à la base n'a créé que deux ports
de pellos
pourquoi il n'a pas créé tout le monde
d'un coup et puis tout le monde immortel
et puis bof voilà
pourquoi il a créé deux pelos de pellos
qui à la base était immortel est censé
se reproduire donc c'est complètement
con parce que s'ils sont immortels est
censé se reproduire avec leur
progéniture est aussi mortelle
autant dire que
parce qu'ils sont censés peupler la
terre je rappelle donc voilà ici créé
que deux pelles au sens et peupler la
terre et que ces deux polos sont
immortels je veux dire l'épuisement des
ressources il va vite arriver alors là
il y aura pas thanos pour claquer des
doigts donc ça aussi c'est débile donc
la première raison ouais c'est que
l'évolution l'évolution est vrai parce
qu'on meurt et que et que la mort est
très très explicable du point de vue
évolutif elle ne l'est pas du tout du
point de vue créationnistes il n'y a pas
de raison pour laquelle on devrait
mourir
voilà un truc que j'ai pas mentionné
tout à l'heure à propos du dessein
intelligent mais si le dessein
intelligent est vrai pourquoi on fait
caca vraiment il ya vraiment un mec il
ya vraiment un dieu là haut qui s'est
dit tiens on va leur faire faire caca
je veux dire c'est c'est inconfortable
ça pue ça prend du temps ça te rend
vulnérable mais pendant un moment en
tout cas si vous n'êtes pas dans la
chaux de sécurité de votre salle de bain
ça vous rend vulnérable pendant un
moment et c'est pas hygiénique
et en plus et en plus ce qu'on fait caca
en réalité il ya encore plein à manger
dedans donc en plus notre digestion est
d'une inefficacité absolument
c'est déplorable
comme notre respiration d'ailleurs un
l'air qu'on inspire il est à 21%
d'oxygène si je ne m'abuse l'air con
expliquait il à 17% te diront
respiration elle est extrêmement
inefficace pourquoi pourquoi est ce
qu'on prend pas une bonne goulée d'air
toutes les deux heures et puis on l'est
on exploite à 100% voilà ça ce serait
efficace ça ce serait intelligent mais
ça ne l'est pas
ce n'est pas intelligent c'est juste ce
qu'il faut et juste ce qu'il faut
d'efficacité c'est exactement ce qu'on
attend de la sélection naturelle de
l'air il y en a à volonté donc pourquoi
s'emmerder à être ultra efficace ça
c'est la façon de réfléchir de la
sélection naturelle la façon de
réfléchir d'un ingénieur c'est de l'air
il y en a et je veux que ma machine
l'exploitation % et pouf une goulée
d'air on a carte pendant deux heures et
une fois qu'il ya zéro pourcent
d'oxygène ont la rage voilà ça c'est de
l'intérêt ça c'est du dessein
intelligent
bref donc là il parle des organes
relictuelle évidemment en nous disant
l'appendice jeu j'en reviens à mon avis
en disant l'appendice il a un rôle alors
il a un rôle il conserve des bactéries
pour le reste de l'intestin ça on me l'a
ressorti plein de fois aussi y compris
des gens qui sont pros créationnistes
d'ailleurs mais s'il a pas d'ici là un
rôle non c'est pas parce que vos
testicules sont capables de soulever 3
kg que vaut steek hull ont évolué pour
ça
c'est pas parce que votre scrotum est
capable de rester accrochés à trois
kilos de masse de 3 kg de de fonte que
votre scrotum a évolué pour soutenir
trois kilos de fonte c'est pas parce à
l'évolution l'évolution c'est pas tout
et adaptation wii il se trouve que
l'appendice est un organe relictuelle et
que cet organe relictuelle du fait que
c'est un espèce de crochets de merde qui
finit en cul-de-sac il ya plein brun qui
se foutent dans et ce brin voilà mon
accent du nord qui revient il ya plein
de brun qui se foutent dans et ce brin
là bas c'est une c'est un pot pourri de
bactéries et qui a l'occasion quand vous
prenez trop d'antibiotiques vont
effectivement repos pur
repeupler votre côlon bon bah d'accord
enfin votre intestin bon bah d'accord ok
conséquence heureuse d'un organe
relictuelle certes mais c'est pas
forcément pour ça qu'il existe
les bras du t-rex pareil hein exactement
pareil les bras du t-rex un je vous vois
la joue à l'art en train de me faire un
commentaire sur les bras du t-rex nana
les bras du t-rex c'est pas parce qu'ils
sont capables de soulever de 100 kg
qu'ils ont évolué pour ça
les bras du t-rex ils sont relictuelle
ces deux petits bras chétif comparé à la
masse de l'animal ces deux petits bras
chétif tout pourri avec juste deux
doigts qui servent à rien et ses bras je
suis convaincu qu'ils servaient à rien
c'est juste que oui bah ils sont
capables de soulever de 100 kg tu as vu
la taille du bestiau évidemment
heureusement que ces masses et ses
petits bras même touché tiff sont
toujours capables de soulever 200 kg bat
enfin ça veut pas dire que ça veut pas
dire qu'ils soulevaient de 100 kg avec
ses bras il n'a pas besoin de bras t-rex
vous avez vu la tête qu'il a besoin de
bras comme un oiseau il n'a pas besoin
de ses bras autrement que pour voler
l'oiseau en oiseau de proie il est
capable de déchiqueter sa proie avec ses
serres et son bec la pose de ces zèle
bâtir est que c'est pareil ses pieds sa
bouche gigantesque n'a pas besoin de ses
bras ses bras son reliques du coup ses
bras son rôle actuel alors oui ils ont
une petite mobilité oui sont capables de
soulever une petite charge
on n'en attend pas moins d'un organe
relictuelle d'une bestiole qui fait 7
tonnes
voilà j'ai envie de dire donc donc voilà
c'est ça un organe relictuelle faut
arrêter le tout adaptatif comme ça pour
arrêter de tout interprété par
l'adaptation sais c'est pas parce qu'il
ya une fonction que cette fonction a
forcément valeur adaptative
c'est non la réponse est non
voilà et va maintenant je voulais savoir
un débat sur la fonction crée l'organe
ou je sais pas quoi les trucs qu'on nous
dit les trucs qu'on nous dit au lycée
sans nous les expliquer est-ce que la
fonction crée l'organe réciproquement il
ya fonction ia organes des fois la
fonction existe avant l'organe des fois
l'organe avant la fonction on appelle ça
une réadaptation et puis ben il faut
regarder au cas par cas y'a pas de
rouille a pas de règles il n'y a pas de
règles il ya des fois il ya une fonction
il ya une fonction il ya un organe et
pourtant il n'y a pas de lien entre les
deux c'est le cas de l'appendice par
exemple il ya une fonction il ya
l'organe la fonction les bactéries
l'organe c'est l'appendice ça fasse un
peu une population de bactéries j'ai
envie de dire de sauvegarde la l'organe
c'est l'appendice et pourtant ça veut
pas forcément dire que les deux sont
reliés par une adaptation ça veut pas
forcément dire que la présence de cet
organe est pour cette fonction la
herray ah bah oui on vous avait prévenu
que ce n'était pas facile à la biologie
évolutive
a donc maintenant le coccyx
c'est pas ce que ça veut dire
alors déjà le tail bonne pour coccyx bon
ben c'est un anglicisme ça ne marche
qu'en anglais en français on appelle ça
un coccyx et rien d'autre donc et la
notion qu'il dérive enfin la notion que
le coccyx est une ancienne que vient du
fait que le coccyx effet deux vertèbres
comme une queue qu'il est située là où
il y avait une queue mais que l'être
humain n'a pas de queue il a un coccyx
donc à part dire l'être humain avait une
queue mais il en a plu parce que
maintenant c'est ce petit bout qui c'est
qui est devenu le coccyx il ya pas
d'autres théories possibles le dire là
pour le coup il n'y a pas d'autre façon
d'interpréter le coccyx comme ça après
dire que le coccyx n'a aucun rôle je
suis d'accord c'est pas vrai le coccyx
il a des attaches musculaire dessus
c'est vrai c'est vrai mais encore une
fois la fonction n'est pas l'organe
c'est pas parce qu'il ya des repas ce
qui a des muscles attaché sur le coccyx
que le coccyx a évolué spécifiquement
pour la tâche de ses muscles ça c'est
pas vrai
la tâche
et bim voilà exactement mais le fait que
le coccyx servent de point la tâche pour
ses muscles ça veut ça peut tout aussi
bien vouloir dire que les muscles se
sont accommodés du fait que la queue
s'est transformé en coccyx
les muscles il faut toujours qu'ils
s'attachent quelque part et c'est
peut-être probablement pour ça qu'il
reste juste un coccyx d'ailleurs qu'il
reste quand même un coccyx pardon c'est
parce que il ya quand même des muscles
qui doivent s'attacher quelque part et
que le coccyx enfin la queue et l heure
seulement leur seul point la tâche donc
c'est pour ça qu'ils restent quand même
un coccyx
voilà je suis désolé c'est pas faut
encore une fois faut pas tout simplifié
à des adaptations
c'est effectivement la notion que le
coccyx
n'a aucun rôle n'est pas vrai mais ça
n'empêche pas que c'est un organe
relictuelle s'éteint c'est une relique
de queue qui sert encore qui a encore un
petit rôle dans le soutien de certains
muscles
très très loin du rôle qu avait la queue
autrefois chez nos ancêtres primates mai
ce qui montre que là que le coccyx est
le résidu de là que c'est qu'il est
exactement à l'endroit où on s'attend à
trouver une queue il est composé
exactement de ce qui est censé former
une que c'est à dire des vertèbres fut
des vertèbres et il ressemble exactement
à ce qu'on attendrait une queue
relictuelle à savoir des vertèbres
rachitique fusionner entre elles
et là par une interprétation évolutive
jean prat comment tu fais c'est comme
les ailes des autrichiens les ailes des
autruches elles ont des plumes elles ont
tous les eaux d'une aile d'oiseau normal
elles ont toutes les fonds elles ont
tous les
ailes ont tout ce qu'il faut voilà pour
être considérés comme des ailes
d'oiseaux normal sauf qu'elles
permettent pas de voler donc ce sont des
organes relictuelle les autruches avait
un ancêtre volant et cet ancêtre volant
a perdu la capacité haut vol on en
attend pas moins danoise au adaptés à la
course d'ailleurs et on n'en attend pas
moins d'un oiseau adaptés à la course
alors après les créationnistes où les
petits malins sur internet vous répondre
oui mais ils s'en servent pour faire
cela pendant la parade amoureuse web
enfin il pourrait faire ça avec un
toupet sur leur tête ou avec leur coeur
pourquoi les pourquoi les pourquoi elles
se servent des ailes parce que les plus
sont toujours là sur les ailes voilà
c'est tout mais ça en reste pas moins un
organe rituels les ailes des autruches
n'ont pas évolué pour devenir petit pour
la parade sexuelle c'est juste que il se
trouve que c'est elle relictuelle porte
encore des plumes utilisons-les pour la
parade sexuelle c'est tout un
d'ailleurs si conséquences attendues si
les plumes d'autruche avait évolué pour
la parade sexuelles elles
ressembleraient vachement plus à la
queue du paon bah ouais
si c'était ça le rôle primaire des
plumes d'autruche ça ressemblerait enfin
des plumes d'autruche des plumes sur les
ailes d'autruche elle ressemblerait
vachement plus à des plumes de paon cas
qu'un truc noir grisâtre comme sur les
comptages fait les autruches quoi donc
oui elles les utilisent pour la parade
sexuelle ou pour impressionner les
autres mâles ou pour ou pour faire peur
à l'heure
à leurs prédateurs mais ça n'est qu'un
rôle très secondaire
c'est un rôle très secondaire la
fonction primaire le vol a été perdu
c'est donc un organe relictuelle
voilà et arrêter la réalité de faire
comme si je savais pas
c'était ce faire comme s'il n'était pas
au courant que que les autres se servent
de leur plume pour faire son deuil
bref
on se met qu'il fait exactement ça il
fait comme si on ça n'est pas mais si on
sait très bien mais par contre les gens
à qui il parle là bas ont évidemment
qu'ils savent pas c'est même pas des
biologistes pour la plupart y en a deux
des biologistes dans le tas et c'est ce
que tu interroges de moi parce que tu
les as énervé qui nous les a énervé la
thune ou les ak c'est là qu'est ce que
tu veux qu'on en fasse maintenant un
voile à la ronde alors la prochaine fois
là tu t'assois autour d'une petite bière
là voilà tu commandes un petit demi et
puis tu t'assois tranquillement tu
discutes avec le gars et tu discutes
avec de l'honnêteté intellectuelle
je sais même pas ce que je suis en train
de faire là
j'en peux plus je n'en peux plus déjà
j'en suis même pas la moitié quoi
il commence à faire nuit je sais pas si
vous avez remarqué fait peut-être
commencé
voilà le fameux a pas laissés par
donc c'est exactement l'histoire que
j'étais en train de me donner un
oui on arrive à trouver des petits rôles
à l'appendice mais c'est pas son rôle
primaire le rôle primaire de la pallice
c'est quand il était quand il s'agissait
d'un vrai bon gros c'est comme c'est à
dire d'une vraie bonne grosse chambre de
fermentation l'appendice était
effectivement une chambre de
fermentation
l'un panis ne remplit pas ce rôle de
chambre de fermentation c'est donc un
organe relictuelle voilà après il
remplit d'autres fonctions tant mieux
tant mieux pour lui c'est peut-être pour
ça qu'il reste encore un petit bout de
rien du tout mais il remplit voilà le
petit bout de rien du tout n'est là
peut-être que pour remplir ces fonctions
là et à la rigueur je veux bien admettre
qu'il ya un tout petit peu d'adaptation
voilà mais faut arrêter surtout
adaptatif ça ne s'applique pas à chaque
fois
donc voilà elle a là il est en train de
tomber sur le je pense j'espère que le
reste de la vidéo ça va juste être une
analyse athénée n'a pas ce que ça veut
dire que j'ai rien à dire
ça veut dire que j'ai rien à dire il ya
juste une liste longue comme le bras de
gens qui sont évolutionniste et croyant
commencer par robert baker donc bob
baker pour les intimes celui qui a écrit
le ptérodactyle rosegrant paléontologues
bob baker et bob baker est aussi prêtre
voilà
on a on la baie de la par an en france
qui était qu'il était prêtre et
paléontologue voilà enfin qui était à b
et paléontologue on à rené l'avocat
aussi qui était qui était à la fois
religieux et paléontologue la vie
d'avant darwin darwin qui je le rappelle
a commencé comme qui était qui était
aussi censé devenir prêtre donc
il ya comment il s'appelle robert atcher
britannique cherchait un britannique qui
a écrit un livre qui a écrit un livre
spécifiquement sur pour expliquer
comment il fait pourquoi en dieu et et
être d'accord avec le consensus
scientifique qui consiste à faire
confiance aux preuves en verre qui
montre que l'évolution est une véritable
théorie scientifique validement validées
scientifiquement voilà
bref comment ils croient en dieu et en
la théorie de l'évolution pour
humez ça dans des mots qu'ils emploient
dans cette vidéo donc bref il y en a une
liste longue comme le bras de gens qui
sont à la fois croyant et
évolutionniste
donc bon j'espère que le reste de la
vidéo ça va être que des trucs sur les
athées parce que j'ai rien à dire sur
les hôtesses etc juste l'opposition at
et évolutionniste est fausse donc voilà
je vais vous le démontrer l'opposition a
telle évolution liste est fausse donc
fin du parcours bail
est encore une fois vouloir vouloir
vendre de l'athéisme en invalidant la
théorie de l'évolution c'est
c'est du niveau point godwin pour gagner
un argument quasiment
scharbook
richard dawkins ce que tu as déjà citée
deux fois dans ta vidéo plutôt
je dis ça je dis rien
acer mendax
bon qui n'est connu que dans la
francophonie hélas mais qui de quimerc'h
et qu'il vaudrait le coup d'être connu
ailleurs aussi non mais vous le niveau
de mauvaise foi de cette vidéo 18
minutes 13 13 encore
18 minutes 13 le niveau de mauvaise foi
de cette vidéo vient de franchir la
barre où le mec demande assez aux gens
qui l'interrogent dans son micro
trottoir est ce que vous connaissez à un
scientifique à thé connu apparemment
c'est ça la question la scientifique a
été connue
alors que le gars dans sa vidéo a déjà
cité deux fois richard dawkins
deux fois jean relaté le plus le plus
givré du monde paul lattes et
évolutionniste le plus givré du monde
c'est
genre
enfin le plus givré mais surtout le plus
connu
c'est à dire le mec il est tellement
hâte et évolutionniste que même les
athées évolutionniste leur garde en
disant être calme toi mec
c'est ça que je veux dire par gilles
vrai quoi le mec il est tellement anti
anti religieux que l on se calme
[Rires]
déjà prêts comme je voulais charles
darwin en hâte et
einstein c'est connu que j'ai quitté fin
qu'il a cités dieu dans ses écrits
non mais alors abraham lincoln c'était
un prêt c'est un politicien américain
alors c'est à dire que même si un
politicien américain a été hâtée il ne
le dirait pas de toute façon
j'ai maintenant la la
c'est à dire que le jeu c'est si l'on
cité de dieu une fois c'est pas des
athées vous rendez compte de la
malhonnêteté intellectuelle encore une
fois de la démarche si l'on cité de dieu
une fois
c'est pas des athénées
évidemment que thomas jefferson rita pas
été celui ci un politicien américain
si à stein l'a dit c'est forcément c'est
forcément une bonne idée
l'argument d'autorité suprême un presque
enfin c'est le second argument
d'autorité suprême après dieu lui même
j'ai envie de citer einstein si hans
steiner a dit si einstein l'a dit c'est
qu'il a raison tu te crois plus
intelligent qu'einstein
c'est vraiment l'argument d'autorité le
plus le plus péter du monde
est ce que je vois de laurier est ce que
est ce que je vois de l'été
intellectuels se profilait à l'horizon
combine une dizaine et stephen byers au
prize
de la malhonnêteté
quand ça vous arrange n'est pas une
surprise dit il en parlant des athées
alors que sa vidéo jusqu'à présent c'est
que ça de la malhonnêteté
[Rires]
monsieur religieux
qui nous fait une vidéo 38 minutes de
malhonnêteté intellectuelle de question
mal posée mais volontairement mal posée
pour induire en erreur les gens qui
répondent 1
parlons-en de la malhonnêteté de la
malhonnêteté bien volontaire
convenient
contraignante c'est malhonnêteté way
opportuniste parlons-en de cette
malhonnêteté
opportuniste
et donc maintenant on peint sur la
question de la moralité
peut-on être un individu moral tout en
ayant une démarche non religieuse
peut-on at-on autrement dit attendre à
ce contenu quand on n'est pas croyant je
sais pas demande à coluche
demande si les restos du est-ce que les
restos du coeur sont en sont une
organisation religieuse
le réponse et nous en tout cas même si
coluche même si en creusant très très
lointain arrivera peut-être à trouver
coluche disait qu'ils croyaient en dieu
les restos du coeur il n'a pas fait ça
au nom de la chrétienté ou de la
religion les restos du coeur il a fait
ça au nom du fait que que c'est bien
d'être gentil et qu'il n'y a pas besoin
d'être croyant pour savoir qu'être
gentil c'est bien
c'est à dire que la notion que la
moralité vient de la croyance c'est un
peu comme dire vous respectez le code de
la route parce que vous avez eu
uniquement parce que vous avez peur du
gendarme
c'est à dire les athées en gros n'aurait
pas ne crois pas que le gendarme existe
donc il outre ray le code de la route à
longueur de temps ben non je suis désolé
95% du temps il n'y a pas de gendarme et
pourtant pourtant on respecte le code de
la route parce qu'on n'a pas envie de se
faire du mal parce qu'on n'a pas envie
de faire du mal aux autres parce que
faire un constat c'est chiant et que
faire un constat c'est encore la chose
la plus simple qui puisse être la plus
simple et la plus la moins douloureuse
qui puisse arriver si tu respecte pas le
code de la route
voilà un les gendarmes ça arrive
qu'après ben c'est pareil dans ta vie
dieu ou pas dieu c'est quand même mieux
d'être gentil parce qu'elle gentil ça
appelle la gentillesse que quand t'es
sympa avec quelqu'un d'autre bah tu peux
tu peux attendre quelque chose en retour
par exemple voila
je viens de la gentillesse issu de la
non moralité un exemple de gentillesse
issus de l'anneau moralité bah oui tu
peux être sympa on en t'attendant du bon
en retour
et je suis désolé mais être gentil parce
qu'on a peur du gendarme c'est quand
même être un gros connard parce que si
votre gentillesse je veux dire ça me
rappelle une histoire qu'on m'a raconté
il ya quelqu'un
qui travaille à ne pas raconter toute
l'histoire mais en gros il ya une
chercheuse quelque part en afrique du
sud qui a supervisé une de mes collègues
quand elle était étudiante est qui et
qui disait les neuf
les noirs gelé sur les noirs je les
supporte mieux mais que grâce à l'aide
de dieu c'est à dire que si la meuf
était pas croyante ce serait une ce
serait
je veux dire est ce que de toute façon
ça fait pas d'elle une [ __ ] de basse
puisque ça fait pas d'elle une [ __ ]
raciste de toute façon les noirs s'il
n'y avait pas de jeu
[Musique]
est ce que vous trouvez que c'est normal
de dire des choses comme ça que s'il n'y
avait pas dieu les noirs je les
détesterai
mai
mais c'est des êtres humains je veux
dire c'est pour ça qu'il faut bien les
aimer c'est pas parce que dieu vat
l'unir si tu les aimes pas qu'il faut
bien les haies mais il faut bien les
aimer parce que ce sont d'autres êtres
humains comme toi
il n'ya pas de y'a pas à tortiller du
cul normalement
donc voilà alors est ce que cette
personne est plus moral que moi qui ne
suis pas raciste du tout
j'ose croire que non et est jose j'ose
même avoir confiance dans le fait que
non d'ailleurs j'ai pleinement confiance
dans le fait que je suis moins un
connard que qu'une personne comme ça oui
une personne qui n'est pas raciste parce
que sinon dieu va la punir je pense que
je vaux mieux qu'elle totalement mais
alors de très loin
vraiment je vaux mieux qu'elle j'insiste
je vaux mieux qu'elle voilà donc la
voilà ma position sur la sur la moralité
puisque apparemment c'est par là que le
débat est franchement le point godwin tu
le vois venir le point godwin un 10 10
10 qui voit venir le point godwin tu le
vois venir l'instant embarrassant là où
ça va partir sur sur hitler à la
moralité la religion hitler était hitler
était athée tu le vois là tu le vois la
subtilité tu les vois les groupes y est
lourd la tulle entend le bruit des
bottes
allez c'est parti est ce que j'ai gagné
ouais alors bao sa réponse sa réponse
est une réponse d'anthropologues pour le
coup c'est à dire que le viol est
donc rapide longue le viol c'est mal
c'est une traduction
c'est une traduction un peu à la zone
mais voilà le viol c'est mal et donc ils
te donnent une réponse d'anthropologues
qui dit dans notre culture oui le viol
c'est mal parce que dans notre culture
on va on a de la valeur pour la vie
humaine
il ya des cultures où les autres vies
humaines n'ont pas de valeur notamment
notamment et je pense qu'il a dû couper
ce passage là parce que je suis sûr que
là où ils allaient le monsieur avec
cette explication là c'est que par
exemple dans les guerres de religion
ou les où les gens de les représentants
de la religion d'en face ne sont pas
considérés comme des êtres humains
et bien
voilà
eh bien eh bien eh bien eh bien les
autorités religieuses ont tendance à
fermer les yeux sur le fait que
voilà certains crimes sont commis
notamment le vieux donc bon et c'est
marrant parce qu'il dit est ce que c'est
un absolu donc est la conclusion de
réconforte donc du mec qui fait
l'interview c'est donc le viol
donc il existe des absolus moreau il
vient totalement de t'expliquer le
contraire en fait il vient de te dire
dans notre culture à nous oui le viol
n'est est une chose qui n'est pas
acceptable
c'est ce qui implique que dans d'autres
cultures le viol ça passe pinette et
effectivement il ya d'autres cultures
houssin passant comme il ya d'autres
cultures que la nôtre enfin que la nôtre
que notre culture occidentale chrétienne
faut bien préciser il ya d'autres
cultures ou là
où la molestation génitale est tout à
fait accepté notamment bala
chez les musulmans et les juifs par
exemple où le prépuce est découpée je
veux dire c'est normal pour eux mais bon
ça s'appelle de la molestation génitales
c'est comme l'excision ça on revient à
peu près à la même chose que l'excision
par que l'excision ce serait vraiment si
tu coupes et où le pénis serait
autrement plus douloureux et plus et
plus trop enfin est plus compliqué de
vivre avec plus tard mais enfin je veux
dire ça reste une molestation génitales
sur des enfants voire sur des adultes
même des fois donc et c'est totalement
acceptée dans d'autres cultures mais
dans notre culture occidentale
chrétienne de bases chrétiennes je dis
même pas judéo-chrétienne puisque comme
j'ai dit c'est que dans la culture juive
que ça se produit donc je peux même pas
dire judéo chrétienne c'est encore plus
restrictif dans notre cadre morale
occidentale chrétien ça ne passe pas
mais dans le leur ça passe très bien et
comme le leur
c'est ça représente les deux autres
tiers de la population du monde voire
même plus
non parce qu'ils y aller il ya l'extrême
orient russe il faut pas que j'oublie
l'extrême orient et puis l'afrique c'est
aussi l'héritage culturel chrétien donc
bref
voilà je suis pas en train c'est juste
pour vous expliquer je suis pas en train
d'aller chercher des exemples d'une
tribu particulière en papouasie nouvelle
guinée où fin fond de la jungle
amazonienne
je veux dire il ya des choses
qu'on accepte dans certaines cultures
qu'on n'accepte pas dans d'autres et on
peut tuer je veux dire c'est pas
compliqué d'admettre que le viol en est
une alors le viol est plus
universellement reconnu comme une chose
pas bien ça veut pas pour autant dire
que c'est universellement reconnu comme
une chose pas bien
le viol dans la culture dans certaines
cultures
que je côtoie ici en afrique du sud
notamment
les impératifs moraux
occidentaux chrétiens essaye de
combattre une certaine forme de culture
du viol qui est tout à fait admise par
une certaine frange de la population sud
africaine
où on entend tristement des filles dire
des filles de 12 ans dire bah oui je
vais me faire violer bientôt sa meute
emmenée et c'est normal et voilà donc
oui j'essaie de je veux pas stigmatiser
donc je ne vais pas dire qu'ils aient
quoi et qu'on met ou mais ce sont des
choses qui existent le viol n'est pas
absolument universellement reconnu comme
comme quelque chose de mauvais hélas de
mon point de vue occidental une fois
plus d'occidental abbas chrétienne
hélas
mais pour d'autres gens s'en foutent
d'autres gens ils s'en foutent le viol
c'est normal le viol de puis le viol de
filles comme le viol de garçons
d'ailleurs
voilà
ce que je veux dire ce que je veux dire
c'est que là il est en train d'aller
dans la direction où s'il existe des
choses absolument
s'il existe des les absolus moral et
dieu existe forcément ce qui même là
serait faux ce qui me lasserai faut le
dire c'est pas parce que tout le monde
est d'accord pour dire que c'est de la
merde que
prenons une merde par exemple voilà tout
le monde est d'accord pour dire qu'une
merde ça se mange pas
le monde entier là par contre je suis
sûr que culturellement parlant je suis
certain que dans toutes les cultures du
monde entier même en papouasie nouvelle
guinée au fin fond de la jungle même là
je suis sûr que les gens considèrent que
manger de la merde ce n'est moralement
pas acceptable pas seulement il gène
ikke mans moralement
les gens auront une aversion envers toi
qui ira bien au delà du moment où tu
auras nettoyer ta bouche c'est ça que je
veux dire
tu vas te même que tu te lave les dents
à l'eau de javel un nouveau oxygénée ou
qu'est ce que tu veux même après ça les
gens vont regarder en te disant celui là
c'est un mangeur de merde
je suis sûr que c'est un absolu moral je
ne crois pas que dieu ait quoi que ce
soit à voir là dedans
bonnes réponses là c'est juste qui met à
bas hitler
[ __ ] j'en ai marre d'avoir raison
hitler le voilà
of la vache le fais palme ça y est le
fespam le point godwin le point godwin
donc le mec répond bien
voilà le mec répond bien il dit
qui fait les règles on les fait on les
fait c'est un système auto organisés ont
fait les règles et il ya certaines
règles ou pour lesquelles on est tous
d'accord
et pourtant
le mec nous sort hitler alors elle ou
est-ce qu'il 12200 hitler pourquoi il
nous parle d' hitler si hitler mettez en
place les règles et qu'il ait la
majorité quoi
déjà hitler sa magnifique exemple du
fait que les les absolus moreau n'existe
pas vous dire dans l'absolu pas l'absolu
laissons maintenant le point godwin
étant été atteint on peut laisser ça de
côté d'ailleurs je déteste les gens qui
pointe du doigt les points godwin en
croyant avoir gagné un débat parce qu'il
ya des débats où la question de nous
amener la question du nazisme sur la
table va résoudre le débat clairement
voilà donc ils exigeraient la jeu là je
pense que nous sommes face à un de ces
débats voici un débat qui va être très
facilement résolues
par l'apport de hitler sur la table
existe-t-il des absolus moreau
non pourquoi hitler existe
hitler existe et est la plupart des
choses que tu considère comme moralement
absolument la plupart des choses qu'on
considère sacré hitler a chié dessus
c'est jeudi il n'y a pas d'autre mot
hier je veux dire il faut il faut en
avoir aucune connaissance connaissances
sur ce qui s'est passé en europe de
l'est à l'époque de l'allemagne nazie
entre 40 et 42 pour amener sur la table
hitler dans un débat sur l'absolue
moralité jeudi à hitler ses limites les
c'était c'est là où en plus il se prend
les pieds dans le tapis réconforte là
c'est que il il amène sur la table un
des arguments principaux pour dire que
dieu n'existe pas
je veux dire l'existence d' hitler est
un doigt un majeur levé bien haut à
toute forme d'absolu moralité à toute
forme de deux gardiens qui nous
regarderait avec bienveillance
pourquoi à 28 l'air sur la table abruti
pourquoi tu ne sais même pas défendre
ton propre beurre
[Rires]
mais c'est débile d'amener hitler à ce
moment-là du débat c'est débile en plus
c'est pas seulement maladroit c'est
débile parce que la latte et le mec en
face que le monsieur barbu dont j'ai
oublié le nom je dis bah et l'herbe et
parlons-en d'hitler parlons-en donc dieu
c'est tout dieu peut tout faire dieu est
infiniment bon
hitler
voilà hitler c'est un événement qui a eu
lieu dans notre histoire
dont dieu savait
dieu pouvait faire quelque chose et dieu
n'aime pas hitler un jeu reprend dans le
même ordre un dieu c'est tout donc il
savait que hitler allait arriver et à
les faire ce qu'il est censé faire dieu
peut tout faire y compris éliminer
hitler ou l'empêcher de m
ou l'empêcher de devenir nazis
et dieu est infiniment bon donc dieu
dans son infinie bonté normalement n'est
pas censée laisser hitler enfin dieu
dieu dans son infinie bonté ne peut pas
cautionner ce que hitler a fait donc
on a ces deux là qui rentrent en conflit
dieu ne peut pas être d'accord avec ce
que hitler a fait et pourtant il n'a
rien fait
alors peut-être qu'il n'était pas au
courant enfin non pardon c'est avec
celui d'axa entend conflit dieu n'est
pas d'accord avec ce que hitler a fait
parce que dieu est infiniment bon donc
dieu aurait dû faire quelque chose mais
dieu n'a rien fait
donc peut-être que dieu n'était pas au
courant mais dans ce cas là
dieu
dieu ne peut pas avoir la propriété
d'être d'être omniscient puisque dieu
est censé tout savoir
donc si dieu n'était pas au courant que
de ce qu'hitler faisais c'est qu'il
n'est pas dieu
et là on te sort généralement ce que
vont de sortir les croyances et oui mais
le libre arbitre arrive alors la notion
même de libre arbitre elles rentrent en
conflit avec le fait que dieu c'est tout
la notion même de libre arbitre implique
un prédictibilité
or la prédictibilité c'est l'exact
opposé de savoir tout ce qui va se
passer bad c'est l'opposé de tout savoir
ce qui est inclus de savoir ce qui a été
ce qui est et ce qui sera ce qui est
l'une des propriétés de dieu en tout cas
de dieu tel qu'il est fini dans tel
qu'il est défini dans les religions
abrahamiques
près moi le dieu que je connais le mieux
c'est le dieu des chrétiens puisque
jeunes éducation chrétienne mais les
religions abrahamiques je pense pas me
tromper en disant que dieu ces trois
propriétés la omniscient omnipotent et
il est amour
et ben et et la basse que faire
réconforte qui est donc je le rappelle
anne apologètes chrétiens normalement
protestant c'est qu'il amène hitler sur
la table hitler qui est la preuve
directe que son dieu ne peut pas exister
dans la
que son dieu ne peut pas exister tel
qu'il se l'imaginent
réconforte s'imagine un dieu qui est
omniscient omnipotent et infini et amour
sauf qu'il peut paraître les trois à la
fois si hitler existe
assez
donc bien jouer réconforte 21e minute 31
31 ça fait très ouvert
vingt-et-une minute trente et une hitler
est amenée sur la table
et c'est la fin j'ai envie de dire à ces
la fin du débat
bien évidemment qu'il va évidemment le
il reste 40 il reste encore 20 minutes
de vidéos plus de 20 minutes de vidéo
évidemment qu'il va consortiaux nes à sa
sauce et évidemment mais là ce que j'ai
à vous dire déjà de base enfin vous
pouvez arrêter la vidéo se finit le mec
il vient de ce qui vient de se mettre
échec et mat tout seul donc là à part à
part contorsionner l'effet
faire du montage de sa vidéo pour ne
garder que les morceaux qui l'arrangent
et faire preuve de malhonnêteté
intellectuelle
encore plus que ce qu'il a fait jusqu'à
présent
il ne reste plus rien à faire
bon bah je suis sûr qu'il aura coupé au
montage le petit raisonnement que j'aime
vous faire
ce qui est ce qui est l'exact
description de l'allemagne nazie
ce qui est
certain de sac à merde de merde
hitler qui massacrent des gens c'est pas
la survie du plus apte c'est l'exacte
opposée celle a
dit l'air ne faisait pas survivre les
plus forts précisément
hitler il envoyait tout le monde au camp
de concentration les plus faibles se
faisaient tuer tout de suite et les plus
forts travailler jusqu'à en mourir donc
c'est l'exact opposé de la sélection
naturelle donc il m'a fallu un peu de
temps pour formuler sa correctement
parce que évidemment quand on parle de
ce genre de choses c'est
c'est délicat mais voilà il faisait
l'exact opposé de ce qu'il appelle la
survie du plus fort parce que lui en
plus ils ramènent sélection naturelle la
survie du plus fort survival of the
fittest ce qui est déjà une non signer
ce n'est pas ça la sélection naturelle
la sélection naturelle
c'est c'est un taux de reproduction
différentiel à savoir c'est ce qu'ils se
reproduisent le plus pas les plus forts
et c'est pas forcément les plus forts
qui se reproduisent le plus filmé bref
donc la survie du plus fort c'est pas ça
c'est parce que hitler faisait et
la sélection naturelle c'est pas ça non
plus parce que je veux dire
c'est pas assez c'est pas naturel tout
simplement
c'est pas naturel je veux dire hitler en
plus moi c'est ça les camps de
concentration ça a toujours été
typiquement décrit comme étant
l'élimination à échelle industrielle de
genre donc c'est l'exact opposé de
naturel c'est une sélection artificielle
donc c'est non ce sera comme le lion
c'est comme le lion qui mangent
l'antilope est affiché à l'écran en ce
moment est ce que hitler manger les
juifs
je ne crois pas
donc quel est le rapport
c'est là que vous insérez c'est la cas
un montage de vidéos normale à ceres et
il dit qu'il voit pas le rapport voilà
exactement
ah tiens là bas maintenant il se
rappelle de richard dawkins tient
maintenant il s'en rappelle de richard
dawkins tout à l'heure quand ils
posaient la question est ce que vous
connaissez un athée connu un athée
célèbre
il se rappelait plus de richard dawkins
devait maintenant il s'en rappellent
donc richard dawkins qui aurait donc
déclaré et je le crois l'évolution dans
sa forme la plus brute est
incroyablement cruel bah vous voyez
aussi cruel que c'est de se faire
bouffer par une eh non commençant par
l'anus ce qui arrive aux genoux
c'est un processus qui est with un
processus qui est brutale il est brutal
elles limitent pas forcément cruel je
crois que le choix de mots et en fait
c'est la connotation du mot cruel à
connotations du mot cruel a
effectivement une connotation morale je
pense que richard dawkins voulait dire
brutale et brutale bas c'est ça n'a pas
de connotation morale c'est brutal c'est
tout l'évolution la seule phénomène de
sélection naturelle est un phénomène
brutale
ça phénomène qui est qui est pas tendre
c'est c'est effectivement la
reproduction de ceux qui s'en sortent le
mieux voilà c'est un taux de survie et
de reproduction différentiel c'est
brutal
après est-ce que c'est cruel
c'est une polarité morale que vous
n'êtes que vous êtes libre de prendre ou
non que richard dawkins appris que je ne
prends pas
donc confusion de l'évolution et de
l'organisme logeur bas comme j'ai dit de
toute façon
l'eugénisme par définition c'est ce
n'est pas ce qu'hitler faisaient de la
se mettait pas de l'eugénisme puisque
hitler enfin je veux dire
croire qu'être juif c'est faire partie
d'une race déjà c'est une connerie je
veux dire il n'y a pas d'unité génétique
aux gens qu'ils sont juifs
donc et du coup de fête l'eugénisme ne
s'applique pas dans l'oeuf est
d'exterminer les juifs
ce n'est pas de l'eugénisme donc elle
donc même en admettant que l'évolution
se puisse être résumée à l'eugénisme ce
qu'elle n'est pas puisque comme j'ai dit
l'évolution a comme moteur principal la
sélection naturelle l'eugénisme c'est de
la sélection artificielle
bah non
ça ne marche pas ça ne marche pas je ne
me priverai pas d'ailleurs de vous
montrer une petite vidéo de à rendra à
propos de hitler et de ça
et de sa polarité
religieuse parce que voilà maintenant
qu'on a poutre et le mur maintenant
qu'on a à [ __ ] et le mur du point
godwin on peut y aller franco alors je
sais que dans une vidéo précédente
j'ai dit que voilà pointe et hitler
comme étant un soutien enfin comme étant
pour ou contre l'évolution ou pour ou
contre la religion dire qu hitler était
athée ou pâté ou dire qu'hitler était
évolutionniste ou pas ça n'avait aucune
espèce d'importance de toute façon pour
dire que l'évolution était valide ou non
je veux dire et je le répète ça on s'en
branle de ce qu'hitler en pense et je
veux dire
hitler c'est un individu alors oui un
individu à la moralité est extrêmement
différente de celle des autres êtres
humains ça on est d'accord mais voilà il
clair c'est qu'une personne et son avis
on s'en branle
donc voilà mais je ne résiste pas vous
montrer parce que je vous ai donné par
d'état leur donc voilà la chaîne d'art
onra aller la voir amon ra c'est du bon
mais c'est en anglais et donc dans sa
vidéo les mensonges supposée dans les
livres de cours épisode 8 il parle donc
de adolf hitler de son rapport à la
religion où il fait exactement ce que
fait réconforte ici un à savoir bac bac
il trouve exactement ce qu'il cherche
dans les écrits d' adolf hitler en dix
ans ben vous voyez adolf hitler il était
religieux voilà up
donc il nous dit il serait impossible de
trouver un renard qui va gentiment qui
va gentiment être un protecteur dunois
je crois ghz c'est une loi tout comme il
est impossible qu'un chat puisse être
amical avec une souris
l'action
qui conduirait à
l'action acte which brings about se
développer l'action qui conduirait à ce
genre de développement à ce genre de
deux choses une ax tout acte qui
conduirait à ce genre de choses à ce
genre de choses donc cette gentillesse
apparemment serait temps où est un péché
sin le mot employé est
in contre la volonté du créateur
éternelle
voilà
donc ce qui faisait tout à l'heure je
vous rappelle tout le monde était tout
le monde était croyant parce que ils
avaient une fois mentionné l'existence
de dieu dans leurs écrits 1 ben voilà un
rendra il a fait pareil il a fait pareil
en disant 'vous voyez moi aussi je peux
prendre je peux prendre mein kampf et
pouf trouver un endroit où il parle de
dieu pouf adolf hitler
était croyant voilà donc
et c'est pour ça que j'aime beaucoup un
drap et ce qui le faisait pas il prend
tous les trucs des créationnistes
chaussettes il les retours c'est beau
c'est beau à voir
c'est du sport à ce niveau là
bon ceci dit là on est en train de
glisser sur un débat sur la moralité on
s'éloigne un peu de la théorie de
l'évolution donc je pense que je vais
laisser couler un peu la vidéo
fera plus tard la senior on va commencer
à parler des chiens ces genres pour
faire pleurer les gens
vous croyez en l'évolution est ce que
vous allez sur les autres chiens
est-ce que tu sauveras ton chien ou
est-ce que tu sauveras une personne
c'est pas du coes qu'être créationnistes
cf os pesos
[Musique]
est-ce que vous ramenez à survival of
the fittest
voilà encore une fois c'est un cas très
très aigu de idy qui voit pas le rapport
il n'y a aucun rapport entre la survie
du plus apte la sélection naturelle et
le fait de sauver ton chien aucun
absolument aucun si vous croyez qu'il a
raison de poser cette question vous avez
un esprit au moins aussi tordu que le
sien parce que moi je vois pas le
rapport
la survie du plus apte bah oui mais
encore une fois c'est fini il s'agit pas
de survie du plus apte d'ailleurs j'ai
envie de dire quel est le quel est le
prémice de 7,2 cette question de
prémices de cette question c'est
votre donc c'est votre voisin est votre
chien sont en train de se noyer
lequel des deux sauvées vous et le
prémice de cette question c'est que tu
aimes autant ton voisin que ton chien au
moins autant ton voisin que tout chien
donc cette question en fait elle te elle
pose la question de base en fait cette
question elle pose la question qui tue
préfère entre ton voisin et ton chien et
tu réponds tout chien parce que tu
connais mieux ton chien est donc web qui
des deux tu sauves bâton chien parce que
tu préfères voilà
parce que tu connais pas ton voisin et
amener la survie du plus fort dans le
tas bah si tu veux on va les amener la
survie du plus fort dans le tas donc la
survie du plus fort c qui dans ce cas là
bas c'est celui qui aura réussi à former
un lien avec toi le plus fort donc c'est
le chien qui gagne parce que le chien a
formé un lien avec toi alors que ton
voisin malgré le fait que c'était ton
voisin et a ignoré un il n'a jamais
ramené un petit gâteau un petit goûter
il t'a jamais ramené une petite
bouteille ou quoi que ce soit il n'a
jamais proposé
là il n'a jamais ramené les pantoufles
aux pieds du lit jamais une petite
gratuit le soir donc je vais désolé mais
ton voisin bas il n'est pas le plus fort
dans ce cas là le plus fort le fit est
c'est celui qui a réussi à former un
lien avec celui qui était suffisamment
pas con pour se jeter dans l'eau
voilà donc c'est effectivement un donc
on peut effectivement appeler ça un cas
de survie du plus fort
voilà
pourquoi pourquoi votre voisin serait
c'est pourquoi est ce que ton voisin
serait plus
enfin pourquoi est ce que ton voisin
d'un point de vue darwinien serait plus
sauvable devrait être plus sauvé que ton
chien ça aussi c'est un truc que je
comprends pas dans la main enfin c'est
un truc je crois que je comprends dans
sa mentalité à lui c'est que dans sa
mentalité à lui à primates enfin ils
s'imaginent que pour un évolutionniste
un primate devrait être plus évolué
ce qui n'est pas vrai toutes les espèces
qui vivent aujourd'hui sont autant
évolué que les unes que les autres je
vous renvoie et des multiples vidéos on
a traité de ce sujet j'en ai marre de
rappelé à toutes les espèces sont aussi
évoluer le le degré d'évolution est
vraiment un truc purement subjectif mais
quoi qu'il arrive de toute façon toutes
les espèces modernes sont descendus du
même ancêtre qui vivait il ya 4
milliards d'années
et ont toutes survécu aux mêmes choses
donc toutes les espèces modernes valent
le même coup j'ai envie de dire donc
pourquoi sauvé plus ton voisin sous
prétexte que c'est un primate simplement
parce que dans son petit monde à lui de
créationnistes ils s'imaginent que les
évolutionnistes pense que les primates
sont plus évolués et du coup mériterait
d'être plus sauvé c'est débile donc pour
lui en fait il vient ils s'imaginent
qu'il vient juste de démontrer que même
les crosnes que même les évolutionnistes
ne croyaient pas en leur propre théorie
en posant cette question c'est s'est
tordu comme façon de raisonner ces
tordus
nouvelle citation de richard dawkins
vous vous rappelez qu'il n'existe aucun
atc l'ebre
un foetus humain et un foetus et moins
humain qu'un cochon adultes
ce qui l opinion et c'est l'opinion de
richard dawkins et nous la respecterons
comme une opinion doit être respectée
c'est à dire qu'elle n'a aucun droit
d'être respectés on n'a aucun devoir de
respecter les opinions même celle de
richard dawkins
pour la vie après la manger rien à dire
vous rappelez quand je vous disais tout
à l'heure la vie c'est pas magique bah
voila
[Rires]
c'est ccc seule la différence principale
entre un créationniste à un
évolutionniste l'évolutionnisme pense
pas que la vie est magique le
créationnistes pense que la vie est
magique
donc forcément pour lui c'est
inconcevable que la vie soit sortie de
rien alors qu'elle l'air je veux dire
dans son petit cosmos à lui 1 je vous
rappelle que dans son cosmos à lui c'est
dieu qui a créé la vie à partir du rien
donc la vie elle est quand même venu à
partir du rien mais bref je m'égare je
vais pas m'étaler sur la vie après la
mort non pas de précisions j'ai pas de
la question du paradis
regardez ça c'est ça c'est typiquement
regardé
comme un entretien épistémique vous fait
faire ce que vous voulez aux gens vous
leur faites dire qu'ils sont des
menteurs c'est exactement ce qui se
passe là sur ce micro trottoir pour ça
que j'aime pas les micro trottoirs c'est
insupportable les micro-trottoirs parce
que tu vois très bien tu vois très bien
où ils vont en venir et tu sais très
bien pourquoi les gens sont tombés dans
le piège en fait évidemment le tu dis
est ce que comment vous appelez
quelqu'un qui dit un mensonge un menteur
est ce que vous avez déjà dit des
mensonges évidemment que oui
donc est-ce que ça fait deux donc
qu'est-ce que ça fait de vous une
personne qui dit des mensonges des fois
évidemment que tu as évidemment que ça
fait pas de toi un menteur tout le tango
je
sais même pas pourquoi je recommande sa
façon vous avez compris que vous deviez
quitter la vidéo bien plus tôt que ça je
veux dire il y avait aucune raison je
sais pas ce que c'est que ces films
il valait mieux qu'il va les appeler des
pêcheurs elle est fatiguée la dame elle
en a plein
évidemment il vient d'utiliser un visa
c'est bien
bîmes ça c'est bien répondu
seulement si tu seulement s'il ya une
loi
montre moi la preuve de ta loi avant
pour moi la preuve de hualien samson
[Rires]
mais mon bon monsieur réconforte si le
paradis est rempli de gens comme vous
mais j'ai pas envie d'y aller
et j'espère que c'est la réponse que
l'un d'entre eux va lui donner ou lui a
donné qu'il a coupé au montage
j'ose espérer que c'est ce qu'on lui a
répondu que s'il paradis et plein de
gens comme vous mais vous pouvez vous le
gardez
est-ce que tu as que tu as donne de la
valeur à ta vie
est-ce que tu as pas peur d'être
condamné enfin d'être d'année pour
l'éternité bah ouais enfin par
définition c'est après la mort donc la
damnation éternelle c'est après la mort
donc même si je même si j'ai de la
valeur pour ma vie je dire ça c'est pas
ma vie du coup vu que c'est après la
mort
mais d'un point de vue strictement
philosophique tu dit de la merde
regardez là on est on est très très loin
du domaine de la paléontologie en
maintenance
c'est quand même c'est quand même chaud
d'entendre des conneries pareilles des
choses qui sont philosophiquement si
fausse que ça dans une vidéo qui a 4
millions de vu et qui prétend convertir
les athées à la religion
c'est bien mais que tu viens de
démontrer que l'évolution était vrai
la pornographie le désir la pornographie
l'ananas et les choses d'animaux
bah oui c'est normal la théorie de
l'évolution dit que nous sommes des
animaux merci d'avoir fourni une preuve
que la théorie de l'évolution est vrai
et qui compte apparemment dans ton
univers fantasmé de de morale divine et
tout ça c'est bien bravo
bravo réconforte vient de fournir la
preuve que tu demandes un an des jeux de
vidéo
nous sommes des animaux
alors je sais pas il ya apparemment il a
décidé de cacher leur visage pour pas
montré qu'ils étaient alors qu'il a
montré leur visage tout à l'heure je
comprends pas bien
parce que la création et
wemmel et l'ajustement n'y a pas de
création pour les évolutionnistes donc
comment tu crois que ça va les toucher
je comprends pas
je m'en fout de ton opinion et de ce que
tu veux pour moi
c'est ça la réponse à ce qu'ils disent
mais évidemment là vous avez vous avez
remarqué quand même comme le montage
vient de changer en fait c'est à dire
que si vous regardez bien le montage
maintenant il ya plus de réponses il ya
juste les gens qui hoche la tête en
disant au rabais en ayant presque l'air
de dire pardon
et vous avez vu que le montage du coup
ne laisse plus le temps de la réponse il
laisse juste le temps au visage de se
décomposer en fait
et surtout le montage laisse la parole à
réconforte qui est en train de prêcher
et ça c'est fait pour toucher les
évidemment les les gens religieux qui
sont en train de regarder ça c'est à
dire que il est en train de prêcher il
est en train de se montrer gentil en
leur disant je veux pas que vous
finissiez en enfer malgré le fait que
vous croyez en l'évolution je ne veux
pas que vous finissiez en enfer il est
il est gentil avec eux et c'est ce que
évidemment c'est le message qu'il veut
faire passer donc encore une fois il
faut pas se laisser abuser par cette ce
montage ce montage il est là pour vous
faire croire que il ya un gentil et il
ya un méchant dans cette histoire il ya
les méchants à thé et il ya le gentil
créationnistes qui veut sauver le rad en
leur disant arrêtez de croire en des
solutions vous rendez compte que c'est
l'évolution la cause de tous vos
problèmes
et vous vous rendez compte qu évidemment
l'évolution n'a rien à voir avec leur
problème je veux dire ils sont hâtés
évolution ou non aller mais qu'un que ça
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut quand
même mettre au clair là maintenant tout
de suite ces gens là qui se font
interviewer sont hâtés de toute façon
c'est pas la théorie de l'évolution qui
les a rendus à t1
c'est c'est un truc de malade à chaque
fois de croire que évolution athéisme
c'est un truc que je comprends pas je
veux dire
est ce que la gravitation général vous
renvoie
faites vous un athée je dirais ceci
étant dit croire que le soleil était au
centre
croire que le soleil était au centre du
système solaire ont été apparemment ce
qui vous rend des athées à une certaine
époque je ne sais pas c'est débile
c'est débile mais ça parle aux gens qui
sont croyants jeu c'est à dire sa prêche
des convertis là évidemment
non tu vois ils ont même pas de bibles
les gens sont ils sont ratés que
évolution
win bischoff gauche si vous suivez les
vidéos d'un serment d'aix ces genres le
cadeau gratuit d'entrer dans le club tu
sais
ça doit vous rappeler des choses que la
servant d' axa des merengue récemment
voilà j'ai limite envie de médecins en
avance rapide parce que honnêtement ça
ça ne parle plus du taux d'évolution et
je ne pense pas que ça parlera encore
d'évolution
dans les prochaines minutes attend des
vitesses de lecture ans et demi
voilà donc la parole de dieu les livres
de science je vous êtes un primate
c'est après c'est bien parce que
tu parles de primates donc ils essayent
encore de relier ça quand même à la
théorie de l'évolution mais c'est
c'est donc il admet maintenant et on est
quand même d'accord que maintenant il
admet quand même que qu'on ait des
primates tout en disant l'évolution
c'est bullshit mais maintenant on admet
qu'on ait des primates alors est ce que
c
est ce que c'est est ce que cette vidéo
va quelque part il vient quand même de
se contredire la donc tout à l'heure une
dizaine on n'est pas des primates et
maintenant on est des primates
c'est quand même choquant
ça veut rien dire ce que tu fais m je ne
comprends pas ta démarche c'est marrant
parce que quand on décortique la
démarche en fait on se rend compte
qu'ils se contredit sans arrêt donc il
se contredit avec le lat et célèbre
richard dawkins il se contredit
maintenant en disant vous êtes un
primate vous êtes un animal il a dit
aussi tout à l'heure ce qui implique
clairement que voilà théorie de
l'évolution voilà
mais du coup
faut vraiment faut vraiment décortiquer
la vidéo quoi faut s'arrêter sur ce
qu'il dit est dit attendez vous dire
n'importe quoi
ouais merci casse toi par pitié
vous voyez le 10ème day will be dancing
aaa voilà ça y est ça repart enfin un
peu d'évolution en faut que je laisse
les sous titres mais par contre faut que
je repasse en vitesse normale
donc anatomical close to human evolution
x me fiche ça j'ai bien envie de voir ça
tomic cloud for human revolution
fiche
alors
bye a tout simplement
donc voilà l'article de la bbc vous avez
l'épreuve donc les indices anatomique
que les humains sont descendants des
poissons bien prenez des choses qui sont
typiquement des choses de poissons comme
par exemple les branchies les branchies
sont des choses de poissons les
branchies c'est un trou donc les
poissons aspire de l'eau qui a de
l'oxygène par la bouche est là font
ressortir par l'arrière par leurs
branchies et donc filtre l'air
l'oxygène je veux dire qu'il se trouve
dans l'eau grâce à leurs branchies donc
ils disaient qu'ils arrivent à extraire
l'oxygène qui sort de l'eau qui sort de
l'eau qui se trouve dissous dans l'eau
et en quoi ça c'est quelque chose qu'on
retrouve chez nous bah tout simplement
parce que l'être humain a beau vivre
dans un environnement qui remplit
d'oxygène
quel est le seul endroit par où l'être
humain absorbe
est capable d'absorber de l'oxygène ce
sont ses poumons poumons qui sont un
milieu fermé remplis de liquide ben oui
à toutes vos alvéoles sont complètement
recouverte de mucus et le mucus de l'air
qui vous entourent sert à dissoudre
l'oxygène pour qu'il puisse être inspiré
par vos poumons
ce qui est un signe évident que la
biologie humaine
être totalement dépendante de l'eau et
elle est totalement dépendante de l'eau
parce que on est descendant des poissons
tout dans notre biologie est absolument
catégoriquement liés allo et ça c'est
parce qu'on est descendant des poissons
poissons qui sont eux-mêmes descendants
de bactéries la vie est apparue dans
l'eau et c'est pour ça que tout la forme
de biologie ce dans le monde est
indissociable de ce solvant élémentaire
si la vie était apparu dans le picrate
et bien notre sens serait fait à 70% de
pinard
voilà
c'est non mais c'est qu'on va dire parce
que ça ressemble presque à une
tautologie mais ça ressemble à une
tautologie parce qu'il n'ya qu'une seule
forme parce que la vie n'était apparu
qu'une fois en réalité mais la vérité
c'est que tout notre biologie dépend de
l'eau et ça on le doit à nos ancêtres
poisson qui eux mêmes le doivent à leurs
ancêtres bactéries le tout étant le
doubs parce que nous venons de
d'éléments qui vivaient dans l'autre
fois donc toute notre biologie est
infiniment dépendant de l'eau donc les
branchies donc je disais donc déjà il ya
le fait que nous ne pouvons extraire
l'oxygène qu'à travers une interface
aqueuse ça c'est très poisson comme
caractère mais en plus
un autre signe que nous sommes des
poissons c'est qu'il nous reste au moins
une branche ea parce que les branchies
elle était située donc à l'arrière de la
tête là comme je voulais dit c'est là
votre épaule c'est votre ancien no percu
lé
donc les branches et elles étaient
situées là et en fait il existe un trou
si vous y réfléchissez bien
les branchies c'est un trou qui va de la
bouche jusqu'à l'extérieur c'est ça les
branchies donc et un trou qui va de la
bouche jusqu'à l'extérieur derrière vous
en connaissez un c'est la trompe
d'eustache savez la raison pour laquelle
quand vous souffler comme ça ça crée une
dépression qui va faire votre votre
tapant la trompe d'eustache c'est un
trou qui va de votre bouche qui remonte
vers l'arrière et qui sort par ici bon
s'il y avait pas de tampon évidemment un
tympan normalement il n'y a pas de
communication directe mais voilà ça sent
par là par l'oreille donc l'oreille
n'est pas une branche ea par contre la
trompe d'eustache c'est une ancienne
branche ea c'est ce qu'on appelle le spi
racle chez les ch et les poissons donc
il vous reste au moins une branche y au
moins un orifice branche chiale j'ai
envie de dire c'est plutôt un orifice
blanchir qu'une branche
donc voilà qu'est ce qui vous vient de
vos ancêtres poisson en fait la totalité
de notre anatomie vient des poissons
mais j'essaye vraiment de trouver des
trucs qu'on associe uniquement aux
poissons et un truc qu'on associe aux
poissons et bien c'est l'eau salée ben
oui les poissons sa vie dans la mer sa
vie dans l'eau salée et l'eau salée ou
est ce qu'on la trouve chez nous dans
vos yeux dans vos yeux les biens qui
commence à piquer depuis le temps que je
suis sur cette vidéo les l'eau salée
dans vos yeux basse et l'eau de mer
c'est de l'eau de mer parce que votre
votre oeil est un oeil de poissons qui
s'est adaptée pour voir sur terre le
problème c'est que votre oeil de
poissons bas il a besoin d'eau
il a besoin d'eau pour fonctionner parce
que sinon il se dessèchent il craque et
il fonctionne plus donc qu'est-ce qu'on
fait ben on sécrète des larmes on
sécrète des larmes qui lubrifie votre
oeil et qui remplace l'eau de mer qui
autrefois garder votre petit oeil bien
propre et bien hydrater votre votre pu
votre lentilles voilà la lentille qui
recouvre votre oeil
était bien hydraté autrefois ceci dit
j'allais dire la pupille mais la pupille
aussi elle baigne dans un liquide 1
c'est pareil
tous assez de liquide le liquide
toujours le liquide bon bref donc voilà
on a même emporté un petit peu d'eau de
mer avec nous dans nos glandes
lacrymales est tellement on est des
poissons bref alors qu'est ce qui lie
cet article
mais bon ça parle évidemment des du
développement de comment en fait le
développement des arbres en chine qu'on
aime quand on est un enfant quand on est
à un foetus pardon pas un enfant on a
des arcs branchés aux essais commencé
arc tranchée au se transforme ensuite
aux éléments de la mâchoire de l'oreille
de et du pharynx donc ça c'est un grand
classique mais bon c'est pas aussi
évident que ça en a l'air donc le palais
donc ouais voilà des guides jean laïque
structures sont donc les fameuses arc
branche chiot
ensuite il nous parle des requins c'est
probablement pour ne parler de la
mâchoire je suppose
annoncée pour nous parler des ovaires
donc les ovaires gourdon qui sont
partagées avec les qui sont partagés
avec les autres
les autres vertébrés j'ai envie de dire
mais enfin ça c'est la colonne
vertébrale aussi oui il ya effectivement
la théorie du hockey la théorie selon
laquelle quand on a le hoquet
ce serait à cause du nerf vague en fait
qu'ils seraient stimulés et qui était
autrefois le mouvement que font les
poissons pour
pour respirer et qui serait resté chez
nous en fait comme une stimulation
une stimulation parasites en fait
un réflexe voilà un réflexe relictuelle
t1 justement puisqu'on parlait d'un
regard relictuelle mais alors ça c'est
une théorie très très théorique 1 c'est
une île c'est même pas une théorie en
réalité c'est une hypothèse c'est pas
une théorie comme la théorie de
l'évolution est une théorie c'est à dire
un empilement de fait qui ne peuvent
être expliquée que par un grand ensemble
théorique bien cohérent et
consensuellement admis c'est juste une
hypothèse qui a été jetée la part je
sais plus qui d'ailleurs est qui qui est
loin loin loin d'être trouvé vous voyez
c'est en 1922 voilà par charles osbourne
c'est écrit là en plus donc voilà donc
j'imagine qu'ils ajustent il ajuste
googlers pour trouver cette image là et
puis pouvoir nous dire hey regardez
c'est vraiment ce que les scientifiques
y pense
les humains sont phylogénétiquement des
poissons sarko parisien dans la mesure
où nous avons un ancêtre commun avec eux
vous avez un ancêtre commun avec votre
grand mère vous êtes donc de la même
famille que votre grand mère ça marche
aussi pour la classification
phylogénétique ceci dit ce n'est qu'un
terme classificatoire
1 et les classifications sont
arbitraires nous avons choisi
arbitrairement de considérer que la
phylogenèse serait notre principal
notre principale
motivation pour la classification voilà
autrefois c'était pas le cas avant
c'était juste la ressemblance bête et
méchante des choses avec voilà la
classification dîner elle c'était les
choses se ressemblent alors on les met
ensemble voilà notre classification
maintenance et les choses ont un ancêtre
en commun donc on les met ensemble c'est
juste un autre critère c'est un critère
qui est tout aussi arbitraire que le
précédent mais qui a au moins un
avantage d'avoir un sens biologiquement
parlant
alors que le précédent ça se ressemble
donc ça semble ça pas forcément de sens
biologiquement parlant mais ça reste un
critère
donc les oreilles sont effectivement
sont effectivement un très très lointain
dérivés
dd2
de ce qu'on appelait de ce qu'on appelle
chez les poissons les les oui mais alors
c'est très très lointain c'est à dire
que dans l'embryon on voit les fentes
branche sial se transformer ensuite dans
les eaux de l'oreille et de la mâchoire
comme le v10 et du pharynx et ces fentes
branche sial chez les poissons se
transforme en marque blanche chiot qui
deviennent les branchies et c'est pour
ça qu'on dit les les oreilles humaine
c'est pour ça que cet article déclarent
les oreilles humaines sont des
des branchies sont l'équivalent des
branchies chez les poissons c'est parce
que c'est la même structure embryologie
qu qui donne les branchies d'un côté et
l'oreille de l'autre mais c'est en fait
c'est un raccourci de dire que les
branchies sont devenus des des oreilles
ce qu'on voit dans l'évolution c'est un
phénomène très très lent ou comme j'ai
dit les opercules va devenir les épaules
ou un os qui s'appelle le stap elle se
transforme va passer de la de
l'articulation de la mâchoire a un rôle
dans l'audition ça va devenir l'étrier
en fait donc le stap s qui faisait
partie qui faisait qui chez les poissons
s'appelle lio id
devient pas d'une position verticale à
une position horizontale et prend un
rôle dans l'audition et devient donc
l'étrier donc c'est une grosse
simplification envoyait c'est
l'articulation de la mâchoire plus une
contribution des branchies plus etc etc
donc c'est un peu plus compliqué que ça
mais voilà en brio logiquement parlant
les branchies et les réseaux de
l'oreille sont dérivées des mêmes
structures embryologie qu évidemment
c'est plus chiant à dire et ça fait
moins vendre
ça fait moins vendre des espaces
publicitaires sur internet
donc c'est pour ça
de cet ancêtre commun n'était pas un
cochon ni un humain c'était un truc qui
ressemble à une musaraigne c'est pour ça
que ça c'est pour ça que ça a l'air
ridicule et évidemment nous avons des
caractères en commun avec les cochons
des caractères en commun qui sont
réellement
homologue donc la peau qui n'est pas
recouvert de poils c'est pas un
caractère homologue chez les cochons et
les humains c'est des choses qui ont
évolué de façon indépendante
mais par contre les humains et les
cochons ont des caractères en commun
caractère en commun qui est son dérivé
de l'ancêtre en commun dea recontre
greer est l'un d'entre eux en tout cas
dans cette rencontre en tout cas
l'ancêtre en commun des épis terriens
c'est d'avoir
si je dis pas de bêtises c'est d'avoir
un tibia qui fait qui est plus court que
non c'est d'avoir une fibule a donc un
péroné l'os péroné en français qui est
plus court que le tibia donc dans ma
vidéo sur la vidéo sur les mammifères
j'en parle donc les épis terre
voilà c'est ici
un ancien ouais c'est ça tibia fibula
donc chez le cochon chez le cochon et
l'être humain et les autres mammifères
épi terre donc tous les mammifères
placentaires
xz martre exclu
le la fibula est plus courte que le
tibia alors que chez ingres et d'artres
le péroné donc la file du là c'est la
même chose le péroné est aussi long que
le tibia voilà donc il y a des
caractères en commun entre un cochon qui
sont réellement exclusif aux cochons à
l'être humain et à tous les descendants
de leurs ancêtres en commun la après une
si napo morphy des signes des heures
quand on glisse il va falloir regarder
du côté de la génétique plus que la
génétique parce que là évidemment je
vous montre des caractères qui sont qui
sont morphologiques qui sont visuelles
mais faut pas perdre de vue la génétique
la génétique c'est la preuve
massu je veux dire c'est des millions de
millions de paires de base qu'il faut
nier pour arriver à la conclusion le
cochon et l'être humain non pas
d'ancêtres en commun des millions et des
millions de paires de base est là
généralement la défense des
créationnistes c'est juste ouais mais
alors si on écoute la génétique les
êtres humains ils ont aussi des gènes en
commun avec les bananes oui mais ils en
ont moins qu'avec le cochon et ils en
ont moins avec le cochon qu'ils n'en
n'ont avec le chimpanzé c'est exactement
ce que je veux dire
c'est le c'est pas avoir des gènes en
commun c'est si votre fille votre copain
créationnistes body web d'êtres humains
ils partagent la moitié de ces jeunes
avec une banane bah oui bah ils
partagent la moitié de ces gènes avec
une banane 90% avec un cochon et 99%
avec un chimpanzé
voilà
ce qu'ils racontent une histoire
cohérente de l'évolution depuis un an
cintres en commun avec les bananes qui a
vécu il ya très très longtemps et qui
était une seule cellule
s'étaient pas un truc à moitié humain à
moitié banane c'était une seule cellule
qui avait les composants fondamentaux
qu'on retrouve aujourd'hui chez les
bananes et chez les humains et puis
après voilà donc même en admettant que
les bananes avec 50% de gènes en commun
avec un être humain ce qui n'est pas
vrai c'est beaucoup moins que ça je
crois enfin je suis sûre même
ça reste ça reste vrai oui l'être humain
d'ancêtres en commun avec les bananes
mais cette attendant cet ancêtre en
commun était une cellule qui avait
probablement plus à voir avec l'écho à
nos flageller que je vous ai montré tout
à l'heure d'ailleurs bon écho à nos
flageller ils sont plus à voir avec les
éponges mai mais bref voilà ça a plus à
voir avec une seule cellule qui se
baladait tout seul mais qui avait les
composants fondamentaux
des deux camps voilà à savoir des
mitochondries notamment celle d'une
cellule eucaryote donc un noyau des
mitochondries du goal j étais
donc le t-rex n'a jamais évolué en
poulet 1 faut arrêter avec ça
le t-rex à un ancêtre en commun avec le
poulet le t-rex n'a jamais évolué en
poulet jamais aucun évolutionniste on a
dit ça sauf pour faire vendre du papier
une fois de plus
tu l'as dit à leur [ __ ] tu l'as dit
l'heure on a combien 33 39 il l'a dit
tout à l'heure à l'autre au blondinet là
vous êtes a pris maintenant je sais plus
mais il a dit tout à l'heure vous êtes
un primate et machin chouette voilà
votre voisin est un primate il l'a dit
il l'a dit deux fois en plus parce que
ça c'est pas la foi dont je parlais il
l'a dit deux fois vous êtes un primate
il l'a dit deux fois elle se contredit
cette
note matin en train de dire donnez vous
croyez vraiment que vous êtes un primate
mais c'est toi qui l'a dit avant c'est
toi qui le dit on est déprimante
oui je suis un je suis un primate parce
que j'ai des pouces opposables des
ongles deux perdent incisive
et plein d'autres caractères notamment
des caractères génétiques qui font que
je suis un primate effectivement que
j'ai une vision en couleurs tricolores
comme les autres primates contrairement
à tous les autres mammifères d'ailleurs
bref oui j'ai beaucoup j'ai une vision
binoculaire aussi j'ai les yeux qui font
face devant ça aussi c'est quelque chose
que j'ai en commun avec moi cousins
primates mes proches cousins primates et
mon cousin plus éloignés la banane avec
tige et en plus j'ai pas choisi la
banane par hasard tout à l'heure un
jeu parce que je sais que c'est un
argument créationnistes
rhétorique et c'est purement rhétorique
parce que tu prends la banane parce que
c'est ridicule
de dire le mot banane voilà et puis
parce que la banane je rappelle la
banane est parfaitement adapté à la main
de l'homme
comme le disent certains créationnistes
donc bref la banane la banane je n'ai
pas pris au hasard parce que je sais
très bien que c'est un truc de
créationnistes qui revient souvent et je
pourrais presque faire un loto
d'ailleurs je pense que une fois que
j'aurai fini les des bonnes kg pénitence
c'est-à-dire que j'aurais fait le 14e
début une cage et pénitence que j'aurai
fini la 14e station je pense que ce que
je ferai après ce sera un jeu à boire
créationnistes
il y aura des petites cases à cocher
voilà le point godwin la banane
la moralité tout ça parce que l'huile
les coches tout ça je serai ivre mort si
on avait fait un jeu à boire avec ce
[ __ ] de toi
la vache ces jeux je commence le jeu en
faisant des prédictions sur le contenu
qui va y avoir et puis au fur et à
mesure que je les coches je bois donc le
but du jeu c'est de faire le plus de
prédiction pour être bien fini à la
peinture
donc oui nous avons un ancêtre en commun
non pas avec la banane mais le bananier
en tant qu arbres et ce bananier en tant
qu arbres c'est un noeud carriole il
possède des cellules qui contiennent un
noyau qui contient lui-même l'adn adn
qui passe ensuite par différents organes
it que nous possédons aussi tels que
l'organe de golgi comme j'en parlais de
l'organisme de bungie les protéasome je
sais plus exactement ma biologie
cellulaire remonte à loin
mais bref les organites les
mitochondries notamment les
mitochondries ça a été un événement très
important
le moment où il ya eu il ya eu là monde
avec les cellules sans mitochondries
après la cellule avec mitochondries
les arbres tels que le bananier et nous
mêmes possédant des mitochondries est
notre ancêtre en commun était une
cellule unique s'était pas c'était pas
un truc moitié banane moitié humain
comme comme la façon dont les
créationnistes le présente le laisse
présager
effectivement les baleines marché sur
terre et comme je le disais tout à
l'heure ça fait de l'évolution quelque
chose de prédictif alors tout à l'heure
j'ai pris l'exemple des syriens mais à
une époque où on n'avait aucun fossile
de cétacés donc là je la faut quand même
en revenir
très très loin
avant la découverte de basilosaurus
basiquement donc basilosaurus c'était à
la fin du 19e siècle c'est vous dire si
ça remonte à loin mais avant la
découverte du basilosaurus
on aurait pu faire une prédiction qui m
a regardé les cétacés les cétacés
nourrissent leur petit avec du lait ce
sont donc des mammifères et ils
respirent avec des poumons ce sont donc
des descendants de mammifères terrestres
on peut faire l'hypothèse que ce sont si
la théorie de l'évolution est vrai alors
les cétacés sont des descendants de
mammifères terrestres car ils respirent
avec des poumons ce qui je le rappelle
est le pire organes à avoir si on essaie
de respirer sous l'eau
vaut mieux avoir des branchies donc les
cétacés on doit trouver quelque part
donc si la théorie de l'évolution est
vrai je le répète on doit trouver
quelque part dans le registre fossile
des cétacés à quatre pattes et qu'est ce
qu'on découvre basilosaurus basilosaurus
qui a des palettes natatoire et des
petites pattes à l'arrière alors des
petites pattes qui permet de certes
bonne marché mais qu'ils sont
suffisamment importants ce qui sont
suffisamment l'a1 est reconnaissable en
tant que petite patte pour dire il peut
être validé si la théorie de l'évolution
est vrai je dois trouver des cétacés à
quatre pattes les évoluent les
créationnistes mais basilosaurus à des
petites pattes mais ne marchait pas
trouvez moi une menace est assez à
quatre pattes
en 1981 je crois on publie pas qui c'est
us la tête de basile aux eaux russes
basiquement avec les mêmes dans les
mêmes grosses dans le même musée au
pointu les mêmes grosses dans le même le
même
pas tout à fait rétracter en position 2
des vents mais quand même un petit peu
vers l'arrière donc la même tête que
basilosaurus avec quatre grosses pattes
voilà qui lui permettait de marché avec
définitivement des attaches musculaire
qui lui permettait de marché
voilà
l'évolution est une théorie une théorie
permet de faire des prédictions et cette
théorie est validée si ces prédictions
s'avèrent vraies les prédictions faites
par la théorie l'évolution sont vraies
les prédictions faites par la création
ne sont jamais validé jamais
alors par la création et par le dessein
intelligent le dessein intelligent c'est
plus compliqué mais comme je les dis une
prédiction très simple du dessein
intelligent c'est complexité élégante
or la complexité du biologique et
bordélique à souhait
le biologique et inutilement compliquée
à bien des égards bien bien bien des
égards complexité élégante ça veut dire
pas d'organe relictuelle typiquement
c'est ça une complexité élégante c'est
pas d'organe relictuelle si votre
intestin a besoin d'une petite poche
pour
avoir une réserve de ferments etc etc
alors il aura comme le pancréas ou le
foie un petite annexe un organe
spécialement dédié à sa pas une espèce
de diverticules à moitié moisi
qui comme par hasard se trouve dans la
position d'un c'est comme qui
s'avèrerait être enfin qui comme par
hasard s'avère être dans la position est
exactement au même endroit qu'un c'est
comme s'ils étaient relictuelle voilà si
votre coccyx enfin si votre corps avait
besoin d'un organe pour attacher les
muscles spécifique qui s'attache au
coccyx alors il aurait la forme d'un
vrai bel os qui certes date h voilà donc
des belles des belle cuillère comme ça
il n'aurait pas la forme de vertèbres
compact et les unes aux autres comme
exactement situé au même endroit et
elian exactement la même tête qu'une
queue qui se serait atrophiée
c'est ça la complexité et les gares
complexité élégante c'est pas d'organe
relictuelle du tout
si une autruche utiliser ses ailes pour
séduire alors c'est elle serait
uniquement fait pour séduire n'aurait
ressemblerait pas à des ailes d'oiseaux
elle ressemblerait pas des ailes
d'oiseaux atrophiée elle serait ce
serait deux petits bâtons qui chouine il
s'adresserait comme ça là pour avec des
plumes de paon dessus voilà où des très
belles plumes dessus
[Musique]
là il répète il remet les trucs qui ont
été dit au début
le fameux réconforte
capote c'était une échoppe
voilà donc la deux la croyance la
croyance en évolution demande de la foi
alors que la croyance en dieu non
apparemment et c'est pour ça et regarder
comme il y emploie le mot knowledge of
god la connaissance de dieu
écoutez cette rhétorique plus traque ça
me
c'est ça m'énerve parce que c'est de la
pure rhétorique c'est pas parce que
c'est de la rhétorique
c'est pas parce que c'est de la
rhétorique apologétique que c'est en
faveur de dio quoi que ce soit c'est
juste parce que c'est un argot c'est de
la pure rhétorique il ya que du vide
derrière ça il ya que du vide c'est
juste le choix des mots c'est purement
et simplement le choix des mots où ils
vont en gros c'est comme je vous disais
c'est comment il va se sortir de ce
problème de dire vous il va arriver à la
conclusion là le but de la vidéo c'est
d'arriver à la conclusion la théorie de
l'évolution c'est de la fois c'est un
acte de foi et la fois c'est pas bien et
comment et je me demandais justement au
début mais comment il va arriver à cette
conclusion la fois c'est pas bien alors
croyez en dieu parce que ça une énorme
contradiction ça et c'est un immense
problème je veux dire dire que croire en
l'évolution c'est pas bien croire en
dieu c'est mieux enfin dire que croire
l'évolution c'est pas bien parce que
croire c'est pas bien c'est ce qu'il y
croire c'est pas bien c'est un acte de
foi et l'acte de foi richard dawkins il
a dit c'est pas bien évolutionniste vous
fait des choses pas bien vous faites un
acte de foi c'est pas bien alors que
croire en dieu c'est mieux
excusez moi mais l'acte ii croirait pas
bien donc croire en double et donc du
coup qu'est ce qu'il fait il a juste
changé le mot croire en nos
connaissances
pourriture
prix tueur reto liste de merde
la nature a été créée donc elle est bien
fait et comme la nature est bien faite
alors elle a été créée croit étendue
l'argument circulaire classique ils ont
créé à sa liste
noté noter le choix des images encore
une fois donc le choix des images qui ne
vous montrera pas d'animaux dégueulasse
de maladies vénériennes qui sont
pourtant biologique 1 c'est la création
de dieu la maladie vénérienne donc ça
vous montrera pas un beau tas de kaka 1
parce que le tas de kaka quand même dieu
a voulu que vous ayez un intestin pour
faire caca et ce cas cas c'est important
de le montrer aussi donc non il vous
montre il vous montre des beaux chevaux
des chevaux qui sont d'ailleurs pas la
caté sens du truc qui est pas naturelle
je le rappelle s'il ya bien un animal
qui a qui qualifie le moins dans la
création de dieu c'est le cheval le
cheval et le chien ça c'est de la
création humaine enfin je veux dire les
le plan de base si on croit enlèvement
la théorie
la création en croire la création le
plan de base était divin mais je veux
dire on l'a bien altérée depuis le plan
de base un cheval ça ressemble pas à ça
de base donc bref c'est là le truc
si vous montrant plus ils vous montrent
des machins mais qui sont même pas des
animaux naturel quoi le montrent nos au
moins des trucs qui sont censés être le
produit de cette création divine que tu
essayes de nous vendre là et qui
soi-disant est censé nous amener la
moralité pour une raison que j'ignore
et évidemment toujours terminé quand tu
veux ridiculiser quand tu veux
ridiculiser un évolutionnisme toujours
terminer sur un chimpanzé parce que les
chimpanzés sénat vont rigueur
non je ne m'amuserais pas à living
motors donne comme et je n'achèterai
surtout pour ses bouquins merci ouah
donc ça a été difficile ça a été
difficile bravo à tous ceux qui ont tenu
jusque là malgré mes nombreuses
invitations à ne plus le faire
vraiment vous avez du courage vous avez
de la patience et s e et je vous dis à
très bientôt pour peut-être le dernier
des bonnes kg pénitence et oui la
dernière pénitence l'ultime pénitence
vous avez intérêt est là je vous invite
à m'envoyer mais le pire de ce que vous
avez
parce que faut voir marquer le coup là
faut vraiment marquer le coup pour la
dernière pénitence la vidéo je
terminerai sur une seule note
la vidéo fait en tout 38 minutes 26
26 c'est le double de 13
comme par hasard